e
morning it being 10 o'clock I will call
the finance committee meeting to order
the purpose of today's 10:00 meeting is
a review of House Bill
1583 a non-gain Amendment because it was
changing the law slightly from the
original Bill we are required to have a
public hearing this will be a chime for
us to listen to the public then later on
we will discuss among ourselves any new
information that came forward in this
public hearing I I have many pink cards
here some of you have been nice enough
to put down three minutes and I hope you
can stay to that some of you have not uh
marked on your card whether you support
the bill or how much time you want to
take so if there have been comments made
by a previous
speaker that are pretty much the same as
what you would like like to say uh
sometimes the committee gets a little
tired of the repetition so if there's
something that's the same as has been
previously stated please mention that
and and shorten your remarks so that we
can fit everybody in in the one hour
because we'll have another one after
that I would now like to hear from the
uh sponsor or of the um non-gain
amendment to House Bill 1583 represent
Emer chairman of division two on the
house finance committee representative
Emer thank you Mr
chair I'll start by saying the the house
bill
1583 as passed in the
house remains largely the same all of
the special allocations and grants are
still in the bill the only thing that is
being changed is
adequacy uh what this amendment does is
it redefines adequacy as the 7,000
33561 that was recommended by the judge
in the conval uh education case this
amendment has three parts part one is
the actual adequacy statement and how
this is going to be
handled what happens is the districts
contribute a little over $2 billion to
education and the state contributes
about 1 billion so what we're going to
do is recharacterize some of the $2.2
billion that the districts uh contribute
to call it swept so the swept will go up
by about $400
million and that would give us the the
higher adequacy uh value part two of the
amendment has to do
with uh setting appropriation controls
so that if the if the District sees some
headro because of the dollars that have
been allocated for swept they cannot
raise their
total uh
budget higher than what was appropriated
at their town meeting because that's
already set so they they can not go up
any higher than has already been
appropriated that part two also uh has a
uh
three-year uh ceiling on spending uh
currently it has to do
allows increases by the Consumer Price
Index or by a 2third vote of the uh
District's
legislature part three of the
bill is excess swept which is part of a
Rand decision and also part of the
conval decision uh that the excess swept
in communities like mine in Hampton
cannot be maintained by the district but
must be forwarded to the state for the
educational trust fund so that's the
30,000 foot view I'll be glad to answer
any questions if the committee has
any questions from committee
members representative Edwards uh thank
you Mr chairman and thank you represent
Emer um in I I I I I'm open to the
amount of money that you all looked at
and considered I uh I'm I tend to want
to support your initiative I just would
like to know was there any testimony in
committee that voiced concern about the
judicial branch assuming the
prerogatives of the legislature I I
think when we set up our form of
government it was expected that each
branch would jealously guard its uh
privileges under the Constitution and in
this case it feels like a a judge does
not know
their their boundaries and they've gone
into the spending mode which is purely a
legislative function so was there was
there any testimony that suggested that
we're setting a a bad precedent by just
simply following the J the judges um uh
level of funding recommended level of
funding I think the operative word
there's
recommended he didn't make it a part of
the of the uh findings but it was a a
recommendation that that he had
calculated so I when I put the amendment
together I just took his
number as a
recommendation follow up follow so then
in in in in the in your way of thinking
then have we maintained our legislative
independence from the Judiciary yes
thank
you further questions from committee
members representative Stringham and
then representative walner yeah uh thank
you for your testimony and thanks for
taking my question um the um uh to come
up with the additional funds needed to
raise the adequacy level uh your bill
proposes um Statewide property tax
increase uh did you consider any other
sources of funding uh to make up the
difference no is follow up it has to
come property
could you explain why it has to come
from property tax is that by Statute
or thank
you representative Wallner followed by
representative
Heath so when I was looking at the bill
and then I was looking at the
materials provided by the um legislative
budget assistant it seemed that
this proposal actually is about $100
million um short of funding what we need
for um giving to the Comm um funding our
schools can you explain to me how where
that $100 million would come from
certainly currently the excess swep in
the state is approximately $29 million
once we move the adequacy up to over
$7,000 the ESS swep will be about $90
million which takes the Lion Share of
that $100 million
increase thank you representative Heath
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr chair
for taking my question um I continue to
be confused by the mathematics of all
this so from what I understand the Dr
will set the amount of money that a
school district can spend on public
education um the then they will generate
the amount of um swept taxes that have
to be
raised for some reason is as much as
you've tried to explain it to me I
simply cannot understand how we are
going to use money the school districts
already using and then raise sufficient
funds for swept without having to raise
local property taxes can you please
enlighten
me well
first I won't get into the Dr portion
because
that's I just try to explain where the
money is going to come from currently if
a if a a community has uh
a150 or their Ed local education what
this says is that 20 cents of that will
now be recharacterized as swept so your
tax bill instead of saying a150 we'll
say $130 per th000 the 20 cents will go
into the swep calculation so what this
if the swep was a dollar it's now
a120 the net effect to the taxpayer is
no increase all it is is redefining
local taxes as
swept even further question um thank you
Mr chair so we'll be using I'm from
Manchester so Manchester will be
using money it's currently
spending and then
raising the the necessary amount
locally for the amount of money we have
to
raise without any fiscal impact at all
on our tax base correct
I will put a caveat in there if you are
a excess swept District yes you will see
could see an increase in your local
taxes because the swept has to come back
to the state but in Manchester that's
not the case all right thank
you representative tki for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question can you just clarify
um when you were talking about um
part
two about um municipalities won't be
able to they'll be a sealing on spending
it sounds to me like that you're taking
away local control from each Town's
ability to um determine their spending
no it the the it actually talks about
appropriation it's saying you you can't
increase your
appropriation beyond what it's already
voted on and over the next three years
the is tied to the Consumer Price Index
for increases or the legislative body by
2third vote can increase the
appropriation
followup that puzzled look it is a
puzzled look um so this
is not
limiting a Town's ability to adjust no
their spending over the course course of
three years
no they their legislative body can
increase it with a two-thirds vote by a
two-thirds vote which is sorry which one
last comment before I um a two-thirds
vote which has proven to be extremely
challenging in many
towns understood I'm okay thank
you right I think uh we already heard
from representative Stringham so we'll
go next to representative Murray and
then representative hacken Phillips
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um this involves Public
Schools can you tell me what the
financial impact would be if you're
start if you include your charter
schools and the EFA programs because
that's a whole another um bushel of
students isn't it that's not included in
this is it there will be the EFA will be
affected because the new new adequacy is
the
77356 so if that's the new adequacy and
that's what allocated in the EFA program
yes but that's not an increase those
dollars are already
budgeted well you want me to do the
second part of
you followup my understanding was that
these numbers were based us on public
school students though not the EFA
students or the charter
schools that was initially true but I
think the numbers you have today I
haven't seen these yet so I believe
these take into account the efas are a a
a wash that's just a redefinition of
where the money's going that's not an
increase Charter Schools however is
adequacy plus dollars so this would
increase Charter School uh adequacy or
payments to uh I don't remember what the
what the plus is but it would be
somewhere around
$10,000 members we have 11 people that
want
have input on this public hearing we as
committee members will have a chance to
discuss it further so I I would hope
that we
could give a preference to the public
and not have so many questions and we're
having a work session on this tomorrow
at 10 yes so that's that's for us to
speak uh representative Heath
representative Maria you
finished sure thank you representative
hacken Phillips for a question I'll
defer to tomorrow Mr uh chair in your
statement thank you for that all right
can we go now to the public hearing and
first I'd like to call on representative
cordelli Vice chair of the Depart of the
committee on
education and thank you Mr chairman and
committee members uh for the record uh
Glenn cordelli representing Tuftonboro
wolf B and oopy in the beautiful Lakes
Region and um uh I have uh concerns with
the amendment in several regards um we
are in a uh Cooperative School District
with six towns uh two of my towns um
have excess swept currently uh totaling
about $2.8 million between the two
towns with the proposed amendment
the um excess swept amount for those two
towns will go up to almost $9
million um it is also my understanding
that
um the excess swept return to the state
will actually impact all towns uh
beginning in
February and I I might mention the
number of excess swept towns increases
from or pretty much
doubles but in my understanding is in
February the excess swep towns will be
required to send
30% of that exess to the state with 70%
then coming uh later in the year in the
fall question is with budgets in
place where are we going to uh find mind
that excess money to send to the state I
think that'll be a huge problem for
these 50 some OD uh communities um I
don't know what the impact is going to
be if it's going to be um a special
meeting um to adjust the budget or I'm
not sure what the process will be to do
that so it's uh it's a great concern uh
to many of our
towns thank you
some of us have some data before us from
the legislative budget assistant it
appears that prior to this amendment
there were 49 donor towns and this
brings it up to 53 all of them have been
increase but I don't think we double the
number of donor towns and this was this
was the decision of the court and this
is the way we try to deal with it if
there's some other way we're open to
entertainment
thank you thank you questions for
representative
cordelli thank you thank you very
much representative re
kcom thank you Mr chairman um for the
record it's r kulum I represent
Hillsboro District 30 which is Hills
Boro Windsor antrum and
Bennington um appreciate your time this
morning where representative Emer gave
you a 30,000 foot view I would like to
bring you into the weeds if I may um of
what's been going on at Hillsboro daring
Cooperative Hillsboro Dearing was part
of the lawsuit with conal so um we have
some skin in the game on that um however
I've been studying and scrutinizing the
finances of the Hillsboro school board
for the last four years in in great
depth and um mostly because we've been
carrying a surplus that averages $1.6
million per year and that's before our
trust funds um after trust funds our
Surplus average is $1.4
million and for Hillsboro Dearing to be
at the court saying that the state isn't
giving them enough money and to be
gathering $1.4 million in Surplus money
that they then choose this is also um
1.4 million after they have their end
ofe shopping spray which I would like to
share some of those details with you as
well um you know I'm I'm a bit bothered
by the fact that they're in front of the
the court saying that they don't get
enough money to fund their school when
I'm seeing how we're handling the money
that is coming through our school in
addition to the the
surpluses so most recently um I'd like
to share our our most recent issue we
had um um we had received Esser funds
for those who may not be familiar with
Esser funds that's the covid money that
came through the federal government the
arpa money and one of the projects that
we had um listed to do Under The Green
under the Esser funds was a greenhouse
project this was to increase our outdoor
uh learning space would have been a
great Grant project what ended up
happening is the doe um discouraged the
school from using yeser funds due to the
timing of the construction project
because it expires in September so the
school board proceeded to transfer
$106,000 from our um Surplus which was
from an English language arts teacher um
salary position and all their benefits
they transferred that into repairs and
maintenance to build this greenhouse um
they did it also on a very Sly move they
didn't make this public to the come uh
to the uh body and they did it after the
deliberative session that they made this
announcement
first of all a greenhouse system is an
asset it's a stru it's a building
structure it's going to have a footing
it should not be in repairs and
maintenance now it's part of repairs and
maintenance it's going to become part of
our default budget um as well as it's
using our tax dollars to go to a
greenhouse this is you know this is not
a requirement of adequate
education so we had presented to them
some options to use other grant money
and um for example a rain catchment
system instead of digging a well because
they couldn't give us a fixed number
number on the well they decided that um
because these plants were going to be
growing fruits and vegetables that the
kids were going to be eating that it
required potable water therefore they
needed to attach to the town water which
now is increasing our ongoing expenses
for this greenhouse they're also going
to put in a heater and some fans which
will require additional electricity for
this to be going on meanwhile we have a
list of $9.2 million of um priority
maintenance items that need to be done
one being our high school needs a boiler
and the estimate on that was
$700,000 they didn't option to go
replace the boiler with our Surplus
money or with this excess uh salary
money instead they're putting in the
greenhouse so I have concerns about how
that all comes into our default budget
and everything else and how they've been
able to get away with putting it through
a repairs and maintenance line not a
capital line but I'm working on that
still I further want to point out that
our school boards um at least um I don't
know how many but in Hillsboro daring we
have shown that we are not very um
prudent with our contract
negotiations we had a snow plowing and
Landscaping contract with a vendor for
six years and that vendor last year
decided to put an $188,000 increase on
his contract which is a 15.3% increase
there was an RFP for this contract there
was no competitive bids received the
school only gave 40 hours notice to
those that they notified the that there
was an RFP for them to come to a
mandatory meeting none of them could
reschedule their Landscaping Deals they
couldn't make it they awarded this
contract with a 15.3% increase and this
contractor is now getting a guaranteed
$114,000 a month for 6 months to
snowplow we had a few maybe a handful
maybe five snowplowing events but he
received $84,000 of our tax money to do
our snow plowing this winter again I was
in front of them saying please put this
back out to bid please do not Grant this
contract in this fashion they ignored it
they proceeded on and issued the
contract back in 2022 we paid off the
bond of our high of our Middle School
$753,000 we requested that this Bond
payment be returned back to the
taxpayers the one that no longer needs
to be made they instead absorbed that
into the budget so even though we paid
off the middle school bond to $753,000
we didn't get to see that back in our in
our tax
our bus contract is also increased I I
have an issue with the fact that busing
seems to have a monopoly we don't have
any competition for student is our
busing
contractor going back to the um Surplus
so that I'm not can you relate this to
the
amendment can I relate this to the
amendment the amendment being yes so I
have an issue with the fact that we are
putting an amendment through based on a
judge's opinion of a dollar amount that
he feels is adequate educ education I do
not feel that what our schools are
giving to the state as far as the money
that they need in their budget is really
um responsible and
um I don't feel it ties into this dollar
amount I feel that the schools are
giving the state at least my school and
I have heard from others although I do
not have actual facts but I've heard
from others that they are inflating
their spending and their budgets and the
money that's being reported to the state
is more than really what they need for
an adequate
education and that's why I was getting
into the weeds of this because I'm I'm
I'm showing that in Hillsboro deering's
case we are spending money that we don't
need to spend for an adequate education
these are not costs that are going to
improve our education system in
Hillsboro
Dearing so we had a surplus in 2021 we
had a surplus of $2 million of that
Surplus the school went on a shopping
spree they put in a baseball irrigation
system they put in elementary school
lockers they put in stage curtains they
bought 128 new Chromebooks even though
we have already we had over um enough
Chromebooks to cover our students and
staff so we had we have 1233 students in
staff and we now have nearly 1,500
Chrome books if not more that we're not
aware of so they continue to spend most
recently what I found out is we have a
new fund called the donation fund fund
25 interestingly enough this fund has
never been reported to the doe and has
never been reported to the Dr the fund
has almost $200,000 in it and last year
saw transactions of hundreds of
thousands of dollars passed through this
they took our funds from our general
fund inter fund transfers and put it
into fund 25 and they left
$171,000 in this of our tax money they
did not report that back to the Dr when
I thank you I think you've made the
point and it's a very valid one that the
spending we've been seeing increase year
over year over year is is somewhat
extravagant so I think that's that point
has been made thank you thank you I'll
just close that I left you a packet of
what our finances uh look like what our
school numbers look like and everything
else thank you for your time notes thank
you very
much I'll next call on representative
Horgan
thank you um thank you very much I'm
representing Timothy Oregon from
straford County District 10 which is um
the town of Durham which in turn is one
of the three towns in the U the Oyster
River Cooperative school district and um
I know yes we do have we do have a
program at the mahit school to grow uh
some of the fruits and vegetables I
assume the water supply that goes that
is p
but I'm um there's some things I like I
was uh I was not a sponsor of the
original 1583 but I I would have liked
to have been I just my name didn't end
up on the bast head because you when
were shuffling around and I did end up
um supporting being a co-sponsor of a
companion bill about the special
education grants and they both raised it
uh
significantly um and I think uh I'm not
saying uh you know I'm not saying um I'm
not saying everything I'm not saying
there isn't some wasteful uh spending in
public education but I think in general
you know
we it's not a bad thing to be spending
more in public education we should be
providing we shouldn't be wasting money
but we should be providing you know our
children with the uh best schools we can
afford not the cheapest schools we can
get away with but that's um sort of a
philosophical thing I've got I like uh
what rever em described as the first
part of his Amendment which is Raising
um the um ad adequacy Aid the original
bill I think was 10,000 um both those
address the concerns that um well judge
rof had in the convol cases but other
ones and we tend to blame the judges but
the problem is the state
legislature um we we pass laws you know
and we have a constitutional provision
too about about education but we haven't
been you know backing it up with actual
um actual dollars in in our bial bu
since sense that's really our problem
not the
judges I'm the Judiciary Committee
actually our chairman had an interesting
idea which he had a con he proposed a
constitution amendment to Simply cut the
courts out of jurisdiction over
education funding which was an ingenious
idea not really a good idea but
ingenious idea but that's I think a
better way to do is actually address the
concern that judge ruof and previous
judges have uh concern have expressed
over the decades and actually adequately
fund
education and this does a few good
things um probably raising the Statewide
property tax um not that any of us like
to raise taxes and I know there's uh
some of us in his body for whom raising
any tax for any purpose as a non-starter
but even even if you're on more the
progressive side of the spectrum like me
that's not something I'd like to do but
it may be necessary and um I don't live
in a so-called donor town so maybe I um
maybe have a different perspective on it
but I think it probably is appropriate
for some towns that have high property
values in fact end up being donor town
so it's kind of didn't really make much
sense of it if we have a Statewide
property tax um it should actually be a
Statewide property tax so certainly they
you know that's I mean some towns will
be paying more Statewide property tax
and they're using for the schools and
that's uh I don't not crazy I know
understand why they don't like it but
that's uh probably that's it's probably
sensible it's probably like uh it's it's
probably something that has to be has to
be tolerated in some cases what I
something I'm very suspicious about is a
2/3 super majority for raising which I
think applies to the overall
appropriation for the school district
not which uh not just the adequacy aid
which is basically on a per capita basis
but the whole school district include
which you know School budgets don't you
know there's a lot of overhead in school
budgets a lot of things that aren't
don't go up or down based on how many or
heal few students you have so that's uh
I think that's a bad idea um I think it
should just be a simple majority like it
is now and that will certainly create a
lot of uh downward pressure on school
spending and not as I said before not
that I hate wasteful spending but I
think it's probably better the air on
the side of spending you know being more
generous or our schools rather than uh
stingy with our schools and
also um this does address uh Charter
Schools I guess it gives them more money
which is probably good it doesn't really
do anything about the uncontrolled
growth of the EFA account so if you
um you want to put some guard rails in
the pill like that may be easy for me to
vote for it obviously one thing is I'm
not on the finance committee so unless
they bring me as a sub I don't have to
vote on anything until it makes it makes
it to the floor so that probably makes
my life a little bit easier I generally
don't EnV you the task you have have
ahead of you so I'm um I think we should
I think we should just go back to the uh
original bill is introduced rais the
adequacy aid and and a lot of this uh
stuff and some of which I'm suspicious
of to the stuff is added earlier the
process I you know like this whole
there's a whole section about how they
um how they prate the adequate a it's
just it's a very complicated uh
complicated procedure that uh I don't I
don't really understand of course um I
only have a uh Masters in Business
Administration from University of
Southern California so probably I'm not
as much of an expert as some other
people in the committee are but do you
have written testimony no unfortunately
no I don't but I would say thanks and
that's basically what I wanted to say
I'm just very all right to all present
if you have testimony and you have it
written it will ensure that it gets
accurately in the record thank you I
also wanted to wait until I heard Rend
Emmer's explanation of it before I like
wrote wrote something up anyway because
I just you know this is very complicated
one of the problems many more thank you
very
much NE next lik like to call on The
Honorable Doug
Hall thank you Mr chairman um I guess I
should introduce myself I'm Doug Hall
from Chai Chester and I had been on this
uh committee 3 what five years ago now I
think and for a couple of terms uh
chaired the division that included the
school funding problem and this was
before the conval and Claremont both
cases um I'm here to testify about this
proposed
amendment and I do have written
testimony which why I will um pass up to
you I'm concerned about the proposed
amendment because while it solves two
problems it introduces yet another
problem The Proposal will make the
Statewide education property tax meet
constitutional requ requirements that's
a big plus it will also provide an
increase in the base cost for State
support of each student uh to the
absolute minimum level required by the
recent Superior Court ruling in the
conval case that's also a big
plus I can certainly support those
aspects of this bill and I applaud
representative Emer for tackling those
issues headon I haven't often seen those
issues tackled
headon unfortunately the proposal also
includes a cap on future increases in
the spending of all school districts I
know that some people object to this on
the philosophical basis that this
removes a major aspect of local control
of
schools but my objection is different
the goal that I hope we all
share is that all students have an
opportunity for Education that does not
vary by ZIP
codes this proposal will lock in the
great disparities that it currently
exist districts with large class sizes
will not be able to reduce them to
levels already available in other
districts every expensive special
education student who moves into a small
town will necessarily result in a
reduction of funds available for the
education of all the other students this
just happened in my town of
Chichester in fact Chichester special
education costs now exceed all state aid
so there is no state aid available for
any of the other
students if a district needs a new
building or run ation of an aging
structure the cap will be a problem
because there will not be the
possibility of adding into the
budget for the subsequent years the bond
payments interest and principle and so
that will lock districts which are
already starting to plan for building
changes some of our buildings are 80
years and more old
um
so if you remove the cap or find some
way to deal with that then I can support
this amendment because the other two
parts are wonderful but given the
amendment the way it's written right now
um as it stands
unfortunately I urge you to vote against
it if you can find a way to change it to
remove the problems I've cited that
would be
wonderful thank you questions
representative papich Muller thank you
Mr chair and thank you Mr Hall for your
pass service and for being here to
testify about this um I'm just trying to
understand you said uh you know a cap
that cannot be removed cannot be
overcome you are aware that there is a
you know possibility to vote with a
two-thirds majority I would appreciate
if you'd address why that is not a
sufficient relief mechanisms for your
concerns I I certainly recognize the 2/3
that's that's in there and I must say
that um a 2third majority is hard to get
for anything in any school district
meeting or any town meeting so in in
some ways while it's written in there I
do not foresee it being used very often
if at
all further question thank you just just
as a quick
followup we already have a 60 %
requirement for you know School
Renovations and such and uh coming from
Windham we were in exactly that same
situation where construction projects
proposed by the school board failed by
33 to 67 margins two years two years in
a row it is my experience that when uh
the school board uh did those proposals
the right way we got 57% the next time
we tried and 63 the next time and we
passed it I would submit to you that if
you can get 60% after getting 33 that 66
may be achievable if things are done the
right way which to me is the point of
this amendment that you have to actually
make a clear case to you know the town
voters that those increases are needed
this is already a large increase in
school funding from the state side you
know it's important to put some guard
rails in there to ensure that we don't
see huge spikes in uh you know property
taxes thank you and my colleague reminds
me that for a bond um to pass takes
2third if the if the school district
wishes to bond something it takes
2third yeah the the bonding requirement
Mr chairman um and and representative is
important and the super majority
required for that I I fully support for
bonding because it's the one way in
which a school district commits
future School District votes that can't
be reversed so for that reason I I
support it for bonding but I would not
support 2/3 for any increase in the
budget representative
Emer thank you Mr chair just for clarity
uh this the calculation says less
facilities acquisition and construction
so that is outside of this calculation
the facility acquisition and
construction is the capital cost being
paid out but what happens is after the
construction is completed the bonding
interest in
principle is an expense and that's not
excluded as I understand
it well that's the
intent thank you thank you anything
further thank you good to see you
Doug thank you I'll next call on uh Mark
doto education Coalition
communities thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is Mark
takoto and I currently chair the
education Coalition communities 2.0
which is a group of 26 towns and cities
that have come together to ensure that
any future funding solution for state
aid to education does not unfairly pit
one municipality against another
municipality by mandating that property
tax money raised in one town be sent to
another town for use in the receiving
community on behalf of the 26 member
municipalities I appear before you today
to oppose amendment
105h to house Bill
1583 this amendment only exacerbates an
unfair funding scheme that this
legislature repealed in
2011 and only last month voted to Table
in a bill HB
1686 that had the same
flaws this mechanism requires towns to
tax their citizens regardless of their
ability to pay and give that money to
another town with no accountability on
how that money is spent that basic
concept is fundamentally wrong and at
odds with how cities and towns in New
Hampshire have governed themselves for
centuries every dollar our Our member
communities now rais through swep is
spent on education in our school
districts these are not excess dollars
within our towns and cities
under this amendment funding of an
additional $ 88.4 million for Education
will have to be raised by selected
cities and towns in the town I work for
we currently raise
$16,600 through the swept portion of the
tax rate all of that money is currently
used for educational purposes and we
also spend a additional funds for
Education through the local education
portion of the tax rate under this
amendment we will have to raise a little
more than $1.5 million through the swept
portion of the rate and we will have to
send approximately $1.2 million or
77% of that amount to the state once we
send those funds to the state we will
have to raise that amount again through
our local education property tax rate to
fund our
schools this is a
$2.33 per $1,000 in valuation increase
in our overall property tax rate and our
taxpayers will have no say in how it is
spent
additionally this tax increase will need
to be funded every every year as long as
this amendment stays in
effect similar additional assessments as
you pointed out Mr chairman will be will
have to be made in 53 communities
throughout New Hampshire in our town uh
if our towns do not want increases in
already burdensome property taxes then
other and uh other priorities will be
impacted this would include Road and
Bridge projects
environmental initiatives and other Town
operations such as public safety and
water and sewer
departments our taxpayers will also be
forced to reassess School budgets and
services with potential negative impacts
on education programs this seems to be
the opposite of the intent of any
increase in education funding within our
state members of the committee I urge
you to reject this amendment's fallacy
of free money from so-called Rich
towns the policy flaws in this amendment
mirror the recent State Superior Court
decision issued in November that
decision which is on appeal to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court and this
amendment creates winners and losers all
across the granite state it has the
potential to negatively impact Municipal
and school budgets in many
ways the Ed education Coalition
communities 2.0 appreciates the
challenges in addressing school funding
in our state we deeply care about
ensuring a quality education for our
children and we will continue our
support for a fair and comprehensive
approach for education funding in New
Hampshire but we continue to
oppose sorry we continue to oppose any
plan which requires property taxes
raised in one Community to be sent to
another community and used without
accountability for their use We Believe
such a system treats different towns
disproportionately or differently and is
unfair and improper thank you Mr
chairman
thank you and I apologize for
mispronouncing your name mrot any
questions from the committee members
thank you for your testimony oh wait
somebody had represent Edwards yeah
thank thank you I'm I'm picking up from
your testimony that um uh you may have
an opinion on on the following that
there is um some value to having the
locality that's making the spending
decision s accountable and responsible
for raising the revenues to pay for
their spending decisions and that a key
reason to do that is to ensure
accountability for the spending
decisions and to perhaps discipline and
and the the spending the the tendency to
want to spend what what what what do you
think about this amendment and what it
may do to uh untethering the spending
discipline from the requirement to raise
local
revenues
I as far as how money is spent in other
communities that's sort of the point we
we within our communities within the the
Coalition communities will have to raise
money through our property taxes and we
won't have a say so we don't know how it
will affect expenditures in communities
that receive additional swep that's the
point of that I was trying to make is
that we we have no accountability
mechanism for us in how that's
spent okay so I what what I'm hearing
you say is you're concerned that the
receiving localities that are not
raising the
revenues uh you you since you won't have
accountability for their spending you're
concerned inherently that they may be
making uh injudicious spending
decisions yes you don't you don't really
trust their spending decision process
otherwise you wouldn't be concerned well
Mr chairman I I don't think it is it
it's a matter of not trusting it's a
matter of not having uh an ability to
affect that right now we are using swept
dollars for Education within our
communities and we have a say in how
that occurs $1.2 million is nearly all
of our Town's school budget we will have
to raise that send it to conquer and
then raise it again to run our school so
we will be we will be double taxed for
that operation that portion of our
budget thank you anything further for
the
witness thank you Mr
tooto I'll next call on Lawrence gagman
it says you're from the New Hampshire
Dr are there two of you from the Dr all
right why don't you come
together Mr King mang Wong yes
sir good morning members of the
committee my name is Keen mang Wong tax
policy council with the New Hampshire
dep of Revenue
good morning Lawrence gyon Revenue
Council New Hampshire Department of
Revenue uh the department does not have
a position on the amendment to 1583 um
however uh we do have some concerns that
uh more so in terms of the
administration and and as well as
seeking clarification on some of the
language that's used on the bill uh for
the DRS administration of of the 1583
Amendment uh we're wondering may
potentially that it could be best
addressed during the work session
tomorrow and it will save time for for
the committee um and we probably also
just wanted to highlight that uh during
the last work session uh we heard that
potentially that the uh the the
withholding of the um Municipal Revenue
uh fund uh distribution to the
municipalities uh was uh potentially an
uh a suggestion from the Dr uh that is a
policy uh issue uh not uh not a
suggestion from the Dr um but once again
we do potentially have concerns in terms
of um the administration of that in
terms of the tax setting calculation and
we can discuss that tomorrow we welcome
you to come to the work session tomorrow
thank you Mr Gagner I just reiterate the
same comments and we'd be well happy to
come back than you for putting those off
till tomorrow appreciate it thank
you next call on Jason sens please don't
take six
minutes thank you for the opportunity uh
my name is Jason sens I live in Amherst
New Hampshire and uh I'm an economist at
the American Institute for economic
research although my uh comments are
related to my research My Views do not
necessarily represent those of my
employer so I wanted to speak to the
part of this amendment that would uh
require towns to remit excess uh
education tax revenues to the State
education trust fund the economics of uh
of this are are complex and subtle and
so I wanted to speak to um what the
research has shown about the effects of
this kind of redistribution based on
property tax base um the probably the
foremost Economist who has worked on
this is Stanford University Carolyn
hawksby she notes that uh one of the
primary effects of this kind of
redistribution is that it discourages
schools from being productive why does
it do this because when you think about
the fact that people are choosing where
to live on the basis of quality of
public services and their property tax
burden there's an incentive there for
local governments to be efficient if
they're inefficient then they either
have to raise more in taxes to fund the
same level of services as other towns or
given a a level of taxes they have to
have lower quality public
services so inefficient towns are going
to lose people to more efficient towns
that causes property values to rise in
the more efficient towns and fall in the
inefficient towns that's a disincentive
to being inefficient right people don't
want their property value to fall home
voters as as Economist Bill fishell
calls them will turn out to vote in
local elections to stop this from
happening so what this kind of
redistribution does in essence the
intuition here is it gives towns an
incentive to be inefficient it gives
them an incentive to become property
poor you don't want to be a donor town
you want to be a recipient town on the
margin right the second effect that she
notes is sort of perverse from this form
of redistribution is that it penalized
families with a greater taste for
education and rewards those with a a
lesser taste for Education why does it
do this because again people choose
where to live based on the mix of taxes
and services that they want so families
with a high taste for Education will
scrimp and pinch if they have to to live
in a town where they can spend more on
education so if you're a middle-income
family and you really have a strong
preference for good education for your
kids you might move to a town like
Hanover even though it's very expensive
right so $600,000 gets you a Shack in
Hanover and most houses are a lot more
expensive than that so yes wealthier
people will tend to live in in a town
like hover but also people with a strong
taste for Education will tend to make
those sacrifices to live in a town like
that so what this would effectively do
is would penalize people who've made
those choices because of their taste for
Education they've wanted to to pay the
cost of living in a so-called property
wealthy town and it would reward those
with a less taste for Education who have
chosen to live in a property poor town
um where the uh the home values are
lower the other effect um that that's
worth noting here is on exclusionary
zoning uh Federal Reserve Economist
Byron Lutz has studied our very own
Claremont decision and the effects of
that he finds that uh under the system
that was in effect from 1999 to 2011
when you had donor and recipient towns
people moved from donor to recipient
towns property values fell in donor
towns Rose in recipient towns although
there was a net reduction in overall
property wealth in the state so it
destroyed property wealth and recipient
towns to choke off this growth enacted
growth management ordinances causing the
cost of housing to rise so we are in a
housing crisis in this state and we have
been for several years we shouldn't be
doing things that make this problem work
why is there an incentive to do
exclusionary zoning if um if you have
this kind of redistributive system well
in part recipient towns will do this to
choke off growth but another effect of
this is that again you want to be
property poor one way to be property
poor is to stop development um so I have
just done a study and this is not peer
reviewed yet but I'm confident in my
numbers I did a study Nationwide study
of uh the strictness of zoning
regulations and I looked at um how this
was Ed by centralization of State
education Finance so how much education
Finance is funded by State versus local
revenues and the strength of
Equalization so redistribution from
so-called property wealthy to property
poor towns and I found that both of
those were associated with stricter
zoning regulations so you know if you if
you uh have a taste of people in your
town just don't want growth or they
don't want commercial or they don't want
multif family these are things that
raise your property tax base per student
a lot of research has shown that now
you're you're relaxing that constraint
they no longer have to pay that cost of
exclusionary Zing oh i' I'd like to
exclusionary Zone but I'm worried about
higher property tax burdens because we
if we keep out all this commercial and
multif family now they have an incentive
to do that um so for those reasons i'
would be very very cautious about this
if if the state really wants to ensure
that every family has access to an
adequate education let's make sure that
actually lowincome families have access
to good schools rather than
redistributing among towns
redistributing from poor people in
Handover to rich people in the rest of
the state doesn't make very much sense
thank you do you have uh these comments
written and do you have references to
the uh reports that you've
referenced I uh I can I can email those
to the members of the committee if if
you would contact our legislative budget
assistant he would be happy to take
those in sure I thank you this is
finally some original material all right
thank
you
question
oh all right we're we're hoping to move
along a little quicker now because we've
heard most of the points and and I have
a person that's just going to take two
minutes Sean
par thank you Mr chairman my name is
Shan par I'm on the Manchester School
Board where I chair the education
legislation committee today I'm speaking
behalf on of the Manchester School Board
which has authorized me to advocate for
fully funding education in New Hampshire
we do support the parts of this
amendment that increase the base annual
cost of providing an opportunity for an
adequate education and we also supported
the original draft of the HP 1583 as
well however we do not support the
portion of the amendment that caps the
spending of these funds we feel this
limits uh local authori by placing a
spending cap on education across the
state and the City of Manchester in fact
already has such a cap um Manchester was
was part of the conval lawsuit so we do
support uh the findings of that ruling
uh I think it's important to just
reiterate things that I've reiterated at
the uh at meetings of the education
committee that Manchester is one of
those districts with the greatest need
we are the largest and most diverse
District in the state and and we have
over 50% of our students qualifying for
free and reduced meals with around 25%
of our students qualifying for special
education services fully funding
education in New Hampshire is
desperately needed thank you for your
consideration thank you can you answer a
question okay representative Sweeney
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here to uh testify Prof our
committee you mentioned Manchester
already has a cap on school spending
what's the override provision for that
cap it's also a super majority 2/3 I
believe so oh thank you thank
you all
right representative Edwards really
short I should we be expecting as we
increase the funding for adequate uh
education that the uh school districts
will sign up for improved academic
outcomes or that there'll be a reduction
in local property taxes as a result
should even either of those be
reasonable expectations that come along
with passing this
legislation I mean I think that's a
different way than the way I think about
it but I mean I would say yes for sure
to the academic standards there I mean I
think this the city of Manchester our
school district has been dedicated to
closing the learning Gap since the
pandemic and we've been working very
hard on lowering class sizes doing very
much research informed steps to uh
adjust our system and really try to make
sure that every student in our in our
city has the best opportunity for a a a
great education and I think that I can I
can say with confidence that that is for
sure our agenda I'm as for the lowering
tax uh local tax paay expenses there
that's the domain of our Board of Mayor
and Alderman not the domain of the
school of the school
board thank you for your
testimony next call on it looks like
mayor mcran from
Portsmith thank you chairman uh members
of the committee my name is Delan
McCarran I represent Portsmith New
Hampshire uh I was proud to sign on to a
letter with uh 11 10 other Mayors um
that you have in your possession I won't
read it but the gist of it is that we
are opposed to these recent amendments
um but not opposed to the bill as it
received large uh bipartisan support on
the floor of the house earlier uh this
year um it was important for me uh and
now I'm speaking as my myself and as the
mayor of Portsmouth uh it's important to
me to to come up here um and speak on
behalf of increasing state aid to
education I am uh the son of a of a man
who who made a better life uh for
himself and for our family through
education I believe very strongly uh in
education and I believe it is uh in our
Constitution that we cherish education
we must make it available to all so I
think there was a question earlier if
there was opposition if um if we didn't
trust uh other communities to make good
decisions I trust other communities to
make good education decisions uh for
their Community what I do not trust uh
is the system of which we have decided
on paying for uh this uh this uh
Statewide education property tax donor
towns versus receiver towns it's a
flawed system it was a flawed system you
know uh when it was it was enacted and
you know I'm speaking you know not uh
for the the Coalition communities but I
think the entire system
uh you know the the ship is sinking in
terms of of how we're funding education
uh in New Hampshire you know I
personally believe it is time to leave
that ship and and chart a new course and
I look for you guys to try to figure out
how to do that I think there was an
earlier uh there was an earlier speaker
uh Jason sain who uh gave this committee
a whole host of new information of why
this is a bad idea um and I remember my
friend uh representative of Oregon
talked or musing on the fact that Durham
uh is not a donor Town while Portsmouth
is a donor town uh and that's an
interesting uh thing to bring up because
we both share uh the Great Bay um there
are great restaurants in Durham um we
are you know similar in in many respects
except when you look at how much land we
have in current use in Portsmith you
will find 4% if you go to Durham you
will find
40% um it is hard for me to imagine a
Statewide property tax could be applied
to residents of Portsmouth when other
communities make drastically different
decisions on what to do with their land
and I am not suggesting for a moment
that Durham get rid of current use I
love wagon Hill and my daughter and I
enjoy sledding on it uh every time
there's enough snow uh but the fact
remains the property tax it's not unfair
because well it it's certainly unfair
because you know houses don't pay taxes
people pay taxes and when you increase
uh taxes or valuations increase even if
we uh do our best to keep the the the
the budget low uh in Portsmith the
increase in property valuation is
unequal among the towns and if we were
to have a flat tax appli to Portsmouth
it simply uh would not it would not be
fair uh because it would not be equal to
the other towns the other example is
that a property tax is a local decision
uh that we have because it is inherently
taken you add up all the property all
the property in a town a city and then
you divide it based on your share of
that property the decisions that you
make collectively as a community the
decision whether or not to have multif
family housing the decision whether or
not to invite commercial activity into
your municipality growing the property
tax space when you try to make that that
individual Community local control a
Statewide thing you are finding all of
the flaws that you see in this system
because the system can't be expanded
outside of the local community to do so
is going to continue to pit Town against
town because the decisions that are
affecting the property tax rate are
decisions outside of Simply the
education funding component of that I
implore this committee to look at this
seriously there's a stay as I understand
so you'll have a year or so to do it I
hope that you guys are going to to
understand the moment that is in front
of you a moment to actually solve
education funding and to do so in an
equitable way that is what we vote you
in for to put a aside party differences
and to make sure that we can actually
deliver education at is required in the
Constitution to cherish thank you thank
you I wish to take a one minute recess
to announce that house bill 1633 which
is scheduled for 11:00 will be delayed I
have four more
um four more people that wish to testify
if we hold them all to three minutes and
they hold themselves to 3 minutes then
we will be another 12 minutes before we
go into house bill 1633 public hearing
thank you and now back to
chair question representative papichi
Mller thank you very much Mr
chair I really appreciate you U sharing
your thoughts and uh um I was just
curious when you say that we should find
a you know Equitable way of funding us
education do you have any thoughts of
over what that may be other than that
this is not really the way that you see
fit sure what would you suggest well um
you know I don't know if the the
chairman will allow me to kind of talk
myself into an answer here um but uh I
think that it has
to I think that it that it has to look
at the the the differences um that every
Community faces I think that it has to
look to solve and incentivize towns to
make decisions that solve other problems
uh within New Hampshire the housing
crisis is something that you see uh
increasingly uh you know coming up at
least in our community I'm sure as other
communities you know in Portsmith I want
my children to be able to live in
Portsmith we just got our three-year-old
out of our bed I'd like her to you know
move out of the house at some point but
in order to do so she has to afford
another house I think that the decisions
that we made um in terms of uh some of
the zoning regulations uh enable uh some
towns to continue to to live in a world
where they don't see the greater good I
personally see the greater good New
Hampshire I recognize that New Hampshire
is made up of its communities different
communities I understand that Portsmith
is a lot different than Manchester a lot
different to the Lakes Region uh but I
also know that if you look at Portsmouth
you're going to see a mosaic of
different communities within that one
Community I would like to see that and I
hope that and in terms of just one thing
that we could start to think about is
the burden of taxes especially when it
comes to thinking outside the box
potentially Homestead exemptions things
that allow those types of communities
that see an increase and a flux in
actually start to be able to willingly
contribute uh to this much more proudly
uh and not on the backs of some of the
poorest of our community thank you thank
you thank
you next call upon Tom Enright from
Hollis my name is Tom Enright I serve on
the budget Committee of the Hollis Brook
line Cooperative District I have been in
elective office for more than 30 years
and I'm I'm speaking against only one
piece of this uh Amendment and that is
um the uh uh spending cap um your the
spending cap substitutes your judgment
for the Judgment of my budget committee
my school board and most importantly my
district and uh I don't want that I want
my local control I want to give you one
example
um which occurred uh one week ago our
district meeting our district meeting
would not have been successful um with
this amendment in
place we had uh a teacher contract come
up three-year contract our prior
contract occurred during covid so during
the worst piece of covid so the teachers
got almost no raises for three years we
come up to the current time and our
teachers we we had a problem um we
couldn't hire teachers we couldn't
retain teachers uh and during that time
when the teachers were getting no raises
you know there was a great big
inflationary uh piece to it so our
district meeting just passed a
significant a very significant teacher
contract the highest one I've seen in my
30 years and we passed it by a
significant uh majority and that will
take our problem way that we we'll be
able to hire teachers retain teachers
uh and um our our community this was a a
once in a generation problem that we
needed to solve then and that spending
cap would have gotten in the way of uh
our ability to control our own
situation um and uh I don't appreciate
that um my community's judgment is
better than and the state judgment
writing over me thank you thank you for
your
brevity next call on Charles Smith Jr
from Orford New
Hampshire hi thank you my name is
Charles Smith Jr um from Orford New
Hampshire and uh like to speak on the um
uh Ed 306 statute of minimum standards
of public school approval I stopped
counting after over 100 rules policies
criteria statutes from kindergarten
nurses PE
Square fo per student and many more
after subsection
3.27 High School curriculum credits
graduation requirements and
co-curricular program it goes on to
subsection
3.49 does the State of New Hampshire
regulate and mandate adequate education
in our Public Schools absolutely on
January 20 on 3 January 2024 the
Department of Education released its
newest cost per pupil D data for an
adequate education
2223 for
20323 historical data shows an average
increase of 5.1% school budget per year
for the Last 5 Years therefore the costs
have increased over 25% cumulatively
since
2019 this 25% shift in burden is to the
New Hampshire taxpayers in rural towns
not sustainable for the New Hampshire
taxpayers due to the high public school
taxes we are seeing more people with no
children or family buying family houses
that have moved to another state with
school AG children and no increase in
housing availability thus decreasing the
student population each year and
increasing the budget since Public
School enrollment has been decreasing
budgets have been increasing the burden
keeps getting greater and greater on
every rural new ire Town rural areas are
especially bearing a greater burden
since there is little to no construction
of new homes in these areas the burden
stays with a static group of towns
people in these towns State funding is
decreasing based on reduced enrollment
But Rising cost per student continues I
support this bill and I also like the
committee to think about the other means
I know that you've asked other uh
speakers but on the land use or current
use in the state of New
Hampshire thank you for your testimony
thank you for your brevity questions
thank
you next call on Deborah house from aft
New
Hampshire good morning chairman wer
thank you for hearing me this morning
members of the committee um I make a few
quick points because many others have
already said what I want to
say I'm here on behalf of my 3700
members across the state we mostly work
in kindergarten through 12th grade
public education as well as public
universities and uh we supported HB 1583
is passed by the house we like parts of
this amendment but because of uh another
part of it we do have to come out in
opposition and I'm here to start talking
about the students and the New Hampshire
Constitution our Constitution guarantees
every New Hampshire child the
opportunity of a public education so
that's where we need to start and um
they have the right to the opportunity
of public education funded through the
state defining the content of what goes
into the that education is a job of the
legislature and you have done a good job
of it there's a committee that meets
down the hall that keeps trying to add
things to it so if you have a problem
with the cost you might want to talk to
them um but uh that educate
must be a robust education that prepares
our students for life beyond graduation
whether it's going on to college into
directly into business into an
apprenticeship into the service whatever
they're doing Beyond um Public Schools
or or whatever education their parents
choose they must be well prepared for it
and it must be as robust in Berlin as it
is in Bedford in Franklin as it is in
Windom so as much as we love redefining
the adequacy amount to
$735 And1 we're concerned that this
amendment puts all the tags in one
basket um there is great disparity
between what those students get in
different districts already so if
putting our limited State funding just
into raising based adequacy per pupil
means we won't have funding left to do
the differentiated Aid that helps
students with different needs who are
more more um expensive to educate
because they have greater learning needs
that require more support or towns where
you require more funding because you
have a greater concentration of students
who have more needs or more families who
need more support then we would have a
problem with putting so much emphasis
just on racing the base adequacy rate
Aid um we don't want to set those
disparities in Granite so to speak we we
also have a huge problem with tying this
to the state
imposing an Appropriations or spending
cap on all districts that's a matter for
localities to decide and some have um
but that is up to the local voters to
decide I understand you can override it
with a two-thirds vote because I worked
in a place that had a spending cap in
place um but that's a local issue for
them to decide adopting a spending cap
or a tax cap makes it very difficult to
respond to spikes in um the cost of
things so when the cost of fuel oil goes
through the roof as we've seen in recent
years you still have to respond to that
the next year you can't wait for it to
be rolled into the threeyear average of
the CPI um you still have to run the
buses you still have to heat the school
you can't have the kids you know coming
in the cold um you can't necessarily
tell all families sorry you have to um
drive your kids in because that is not
fair to families who do not have someone
home to drive their kids into school um
so for those reasons we urge you
unfortunately as much as we would like
the base acacy a increased for all
students we don't think this is the
right approach for it so we urge you uh
to find this amendment and exp to
legislate thank you so much for your
time and so you can hear the rest of
these testifiers I will not take
questions thank you for your testimony
uh the last one I have is Zach shien
he'll tell us what NHS ffp is and he has
written testimony so perhaps you don't
need to take five minutes very fair uh
my name is Zach shien I'm the executive
director for the New Hampshire school
funding fairness project doesn't always
fit in the pink card I do have written
testimony that I can I need to make some
more copies I'll pass around um I will
kind of skip through it to just hit some
points that I think have been missed or
overlooked uh in the essence of time um
just real quick new H school funding
fers project we're a nonprofit
organization that educates um citizens
and policy makers about school funding
property taxes um and kind of some of
the ways we can work to address these
issues I really appreciate all the work
that's been done specifically in finance
division 2 and with this amendment to
try to tackle what is a very complicated
and challenging issue um I want to point
out that there are a number of elements
to this amendment and as stated um by
the sponsor at the beginning the the
kind of impetus for this amendment was
to try to address the lack of funding
take into account the recent court
rulings which were you know
recommendations to the legislature about
how to raise additional funding and
where to set that base adequacy at a
higher
amount and to try to address the
unconstitutional um structure that is
currently
swept as past HB 1583 as we've heard did
receive very Broad bipartisan support so
I definitely urge the committee to take
into account that everyone who's spoken
most people who have spoken today have
been in support of that underlying Bill
and recognizing that there are elements
to the amendment that they might not be
in favor of for a lot of the reasons
that you have
heard relative to the remittance of
excess swept wanted to point out a few
things um one is that swept was created
to fund the state's obligation to pay
for an adequate education
is a state tax for a state
responsibility it is not a local
tax that's why that money in the in the
ruling the Rand decision back in
November the judge found that that money
needs to be remitted to the state
because it is a state revenue source for
the state's
responsibility I think that is a piece
that was missed from some of the uh
previous speakers Additionally the uh
letter signed by the Mayors I wanted to
point out that again they were in
support of the underlying bill some of
those Mayors are also part of the
Coalition community and so I think that
hopefully that support for the
underlying Bill extends to them as
well we are in favor of increasing the
base adequacy amount um it's in line
with the conval decision it's a step in
the right direction there's a lot of
evidence a lot of thought and rationale
behind both the conval plaintiff's
argument for the almost $10,000 in base
adequacy and the judges ruling in the
$7,300
one two last pieces one is um I want to
reiterate opposition to the spending cap
element of this amendment I think what
we are concerned about is that locks
into place the current inequities we see
across our school funding system
communities would not have the option to
spend the additional funds they would
get from this amendment on schools if
they wanted to for most communities many
of whom are represented in this room the
of additional funding would far exceed
the allowable increase in their school
budgets even if they wanted to make that
decision locally I understand the 23d
element but we all know that is a very
high bar to pass and locking into place
current inequities um as in an attempt
to kind of reduce overall School
spending I think is misplaced and not
appropriate for the intent of this bill
the intent of the lawsuits the stated
intent this bill is to help address
school funding and the inequities in
there and placing a cap on on District's
ability to increase funding if that's
what they find they want to do to try to
increase student outcomes I think is a
bit of a mismatch my last
comment um is
that we have really good schools in New
Hampshire on
average on average we spend a good
amount of money on average we have very
high achievement scores there's also no
school district in the state that spends
less than three times the amount of
money they get from the state an
adequacy fund per pupil so unless every
single School District in the state is
spending on Superfluous items as was
alluded to or referenced earlier every
single district is spending
significantly more than they get from
adequacy funding there is a huge gap in
the amount of money that we receive from
advocacy funding and the amount of money
that schools spend on their students I
just want to underscore that last piece
that we have good schools most school
boards most school districts in the
state want to provide good educ a for
their students and are trying to do so
balancing the burden on local property
taxes appreciate your time and I'd be
happy to answer any
questions thank you representative
hacken
Phillips thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question Mr Sheen um
I'm just wondering if you would mention
or if you have any opinion about the
Amendments page three penalties that
seem to be set into non excess towns
that may choose not to fulfill their
obligation to the state did you have any
position on the ability of the state to
withhold either any monies from the
education department of Ed or on the
meal and rooms um distribution that
would not be
made thank you for the
question I think
that the intent of that was to try to as
with a lot of pieces of this Amendment
actually tackle these issues headon
instead of beating around the bush which
is why I really appreciate a lot of the
work that's been put into that I don't
know if potentially restricting revenues
from other sources like the rims and
meal is the best way to get access to up
communities to comply with that but I
think it's looking at this
issue as it stands which is that there's
a lot of mismatch in what the courts
have said to do or potential legislation
and what actually ends up happening so I
don't know that that would be the best
mechanism to make sure that EXs swep
communities comply with the law but I
appreciate the attempt to try to work
through how do we actually make sure the
changes in this bill um are
enacted thank you thank you I close this
hearing on the on the
amendment of
1583 uh representa Emerick he will
announce the work
session
thank you Mr chair tomorrow at 10
o'clock uh members of uh
of division two I couldn't think where I
was division two take your paperwork
with you for
tomorrow okay um I have the signup sheet
those wanting to be
recorded uh James Richard is against oh
is uh Horgan spoke par spoke h house
spoke Dave Leno representative Dave luno
is against and Bill ardinger is against
those are the ones that signed up some
of them already testified I will now
open the
hearing on
the amendment proposed to
16 House Bill
1633 and call upon representative
Maguire thank you Mr chairman and fellow
members of the finance committee I'm
here to introduce um amendment 124h to
House Bill
1633 for the past uh 10 or 12 years the
house has worked on cannabis
legislation uh in some cases passing it
only to see it fail in the next steps
either the senate or maybe the governor
for the first time we seem to have some
uh a little bit of of a window
to possibly passing something in this
area um I personally met with the
governor's representative Mr Parker he
gave me a list of um things that the
governor has said would make such
legislation
acceptable number one on that list is
What's called the franchise model that's
what this amendment
represents um the the current bill um
1633 is what's called I think the agency
model or something like that the the the
main difference is that um 1633 as it
exists would create um uh
independent um regulated businesses
right so heavily regulated but but even
so they're they're essentially
independent businesses you can think of
it uh maybe like restaurants or
something that you know some are
together some are different and and so
on but they're heavily regulated by the
Liquor Commission um as far as their
their bar and alcohol sales this bill
creates What's called the franchise
model so so essentially The Liquor
Commission becomes the
franchisor for some number of businesses
and and is even more heavily regulated
right the the what they sell what they
CAU what they charge uh how they
advertise all that sort of stuff would
be in common you can think of it like a
like a chain right there's a there's a
McDonald's headquarters and all the
McDonald's look the same and they all uh
are are regulated and priced and have
similar uh products and so on um
although maybe this franchise that's in
this bill is not quite as you know the
the manual for McDonald's is probably I
don't know how thick but this will be
less
um but but again if we want something to
pass this is the number one thing on the
governor's list there's there's another
10 things in there as well that's that's
part of this
amendment we're kind of in an analogous
situation to what the legislature found
itself in at the end of
prohibition so um when they decided to
create the Liquor Commission in the
first place and um
I think today looking back at that most
of us are glad they did right um if you
look at the way alcohol is sold and
regulated and so on in our surrounding
states it's not as good as what we
experience here in New Hampshire we have
um our Liquor
Commission I mean what's the basis of we
want to have revenue for the state for
all the programs education everything
else and and we get a significant amount
from The Liquor Commission and it's so
significant that 50% of their sales goes
to people who don't live in New
Hampshire so these are people that are
voluntarily sending us revenue and and
don't get services for that for that
Revenue in some sense right so um that's
how great it is and
and the the only reason that worked was
they were at a point where there was no
existing businesses there was no
existing Revenue um and and so they
created The Liquor Commission and built
it up over time so the the source of the
liquor
commission's revenue is the fact that
they have a Statewide Monopoly they have
very high volumes and and therefore they
can offer prices that are lower than
similar products in in surrounding
states now um this bill does not create
that model
because of the federal prohibition right
so so the Federal Pro prohibition means
that unlike liquor we
cannot um import uh cannabis from other
places it has to be GR grown and created
in New Hampshire and in the long
run it's it's clear that it will not be
grown in New Hampshire I mean if at some
point the federal prohibition went away
and there was interstate commerce any
growing going on in New Hampshire would
essentially cease right I I mean we
still produce some liquor and some wine
and so on in New Hampshire but it's a
very tiny amount I mean the the climate
of New Hampshire the soil oil all that
sort of stuff is not suitable for for
major
agriculture um like this you know so so
we're not at a point where we can create
a
Statewide um cannabis commission if you
will to set up dozens of stores and all
that sort of thing but what we can do is
is sort of dip our
toe all right dip our toe into it and
and uh um
create uh create some business that can
later move in that direction right so
some of our liquor stores currently are
called agency stores there's they're
liquor stores but they're not run by The
Liquor Commission this creates 15 stores
not run by The Liquor Commission but
it's clear that in the long run there
will have to be many many more stores
there's currently 73 stores in Vermont I
don't know there's probably 473 stores
in Maine I don't know how many stores in
Massachusetts but the these 15 stores
could continue as agency stores if you
will um but in the long run we could
potentially have a cannabis business
similar to the liquor business it's not
easy it's not
guaranteed um we're not number one in
liquor but cannabis is a somewhat
substitute for liquor and and the
history of people who are number one in
a business when that business goes
through a major transition continuing on
is not good so so this is a possibility
and I think this is the only possibility
that will um that will work um thank you
one other thing just I'm sorry
but the the bill in front of you is not
the one we're going to pass my my copy
is littered with notes right so we are
going to make changes in division um and
and so don't you know we have complaints
from this that and the other thing those
kind of things are going to be worked on
thank you Mr
chairman ladies and gentlemen I'm going
to have a hard stop in about an hour at
12:30 because we have a a full afternoon
for this committee so I have a number of
cards if people hold themselves to 3
minutes we should be able to get through
it by 1:30 and we will remind you of the
time I will allow a little more time for
some people that have an an alternative
um the next one up will be an an
alternative to this amendment that she
already has submitted an amendment
hopefully she can be brief but if
everybody stays no more than three
minutes we should be able to get through
it by uh 12:30 and then there'll be a
work session on this
and I'll have representative Lehman
announce the work
session thank you Mr chairman I believe
it's 1:00 tomorrow afternoon and across
the hall here so um there's a lot to be
said please don't be repetitious if
someone else has already made the points
you want to make I would appreciate if
you just say I agree with the previous
speaker or the soand so that said this
and if you have one additional point to
make please do that but this is a
complicated subject and if you've heard
a lot of the things you're going to say
please don't repeat them thank you um
questions for representative McGuire
seeing none I'll call on representative
Leon for an
alternative thank you Mr CH chairman and
members of the committee um for the
record my name is Erica Leon I represent
the town of Derry and I'm the prime
sponsor of this bill um right now
there's two different Forks on the road
in front of you one of them is the
agency model that I have presented which
is a state-run path the other is a
franchise the other Forks in the road
are do we want to have a industry a
cannabis industry that is aggressively
growing sales in order to maximize
conversion from liquor to cannabis and
in order to maximize revenues to the
state
or do we want to have a path where
people in New Hampshire who are
currently using cannabis and either
purchasing it out of state or from
illicit dealers have a safer instate
model where we have an opportunity for
this Market to participate in the state
of New Hampshire but we are not in the
business of a state of having more
people use
cannabis I prefer the second path I know
that the last hearing says that we have
a lot of uses for money but I don't
think that converting people who don't
use cannabis today to be cannabis users
is a smart path forward I have presented
a bill with with my bill passed the
house and I did present an amendment
that had some um increas some changes to
it it had some definitions it made sure
that their therapeutic cannabis program
was appropriately recognized um and it
also worked towards those Appropriations
I do want to say that the therapeutic
cannabis program is very important in
this state um we just has passed a bill
so people don't need opioids for their
pain before they can use cannabis it's
important and we need to make sure that
as we move forward with legalization
we're not throwing the patients and the
people that serve them out we need to
make sure that there is a path for the
atcs to continue to operate VI viably
and we need to make sure that people who
use cannabis as medicine still have that
opportunity my bill and the foundation
of that bill provides for that path um
what I would what I am planning to
present to you is a way way to carve out
the business model from the regulatory
path on cannabis we need to have the
regulatory portion separate from the
business model um in liquor The Liquor
Commission is well suited to do both
because there are federal regulations
that give us a lot of guidance and give
us a lot of guard rails because the
federal guidance on cannabis is don't do
it don't sell it that doesn't provide
the same guard rails um I plan to come
with language that will have franchise
separate and compartmentalized from the
whole rest of the implementation so that
we can see if the franchise model does
in fact work in the state of New
Hampshire if that proves to be unviable
it won't kill the entire program because
it won't be in meshed throughout when we
had heard had the last hearing I heard
about a $5 million computer system I
realized a lot of people want to have
cannabis legalized and they're willing
to accept the franchise model because we
can change it I realized that even even
if I was the person holding the pen if
we spent $5 million on a process that
locks in franchises even I wouldn't be
able to change that so let's separate
the regulation and the operation from
the business model and set up a separate
franchise I will bring this to you for
the work session tomorrow hopefully
fully drafted if not in the best
language I can get because I know time
is pressing but I think we've come an
amazing way in this discussion and I'm
open to questions thank you
questions from committee members seeing
none thank you Senator abbis here we'll
recognize him
next and I'll do my best with that three
minute uh time time frame I I hear I
talk a
lot thank you Mr chairman Senator Daryl
abis I represent uh District 22
communities of pum Salem ainson and
plastow uh and I'm here I do support the
Maguire Amendment um I will say just
working on this last year as a member of
the house and now in the Senate it's
what can get over the finish line
there's a lot of people who were
traditionally against cannabis anyone
who served with me last term in the in
the term before I've spoken in
opposition to several cannabis bills and
cacs uh this is a compromise on my end
do I love it no but at the same time I
think it's it's a fair compromise and
this from what I I can see has a chance
to become law and I I believe it does
have a support in the chamber that I sit
in and and meeting and having
conversations with uh a lot of
interested parties this could actually
become law in respect to the the bill as
it was drafted and the proposed
amendments uh it doesn't have my support
I don't believe it would make it to
anyone's desk to even be signed I'm just
being as transparent as I can in the
other concern I have is in the Senate
I'm not sure this is going to have the
support of the finance committee so the
reason why I'm taking upon myself to
come to the house committees is that I
believe a finance committee that if if
you're willing to support the bill
should work on it and I heard I heard
some issues with some of the numbers
that have been put in that and that's
exactly why you know having a finance
committee involved in the process that
supports it would be
beneficial going another Direction This
the agency stor I keep hearing that it
to me it just looking at it it's a
rebranding of what was HP 639 in several
bills we had over the years it's just
the new title it's not State controlled
uh it's certainly not um any type of
state store it's a private licensed
store and we've seen every other state
that allowed recreational Mech canist do
that and they oversaturate the market
and what that leads to is a lot of these
go under and a lot of the wealthier
investors they can withstand that and
it's been a problem and I think going
this route having the franchise model it
really creates a partnership with the
individual
franchises and I think there's a lot of
benefits to that obviously you never see
you don't want any of these stores going
out of business
business that's all about branding you
don't want to see that and that's really
critical to putting forward a something
that works together everyone's working
together every franchisee would be
working together putting forward this
this business model so I think just to
sum it up this can make it over the
Finish Line I was involved as the chair
of the commission that met over the fall
so I can answer any questions if you
have any concerns about some of the
provisions in here and um I'll be happy
to answer those but again if you want
something to become law it's best that
we all paddle in the same direction
thank you representative papich Muller
thank you Mr chair and thank you senator
for testifying and taking questions um
obviously it's a 38 page Amendment so
I'm not going to get into the weeds but
just one brief question how do you see
this
model interplay with the current federal
legislation I know that have been a lot
of concerns expressed about the state
and the federal governments butting
heads on this and I'd appreciate your
thoughts it's against federal law it's
all the therapeutic program is against
federal law it's all against federal law
uh I think we want to take it the
position we're either going to follow
the federal law and and acknowledge it
or ignore it but I think for what we're
trying to do I preferred this the state
control model similar to that of liquor
but it's difficult really Define uh
investors into cultivation when you only
have one customer so it's kind of
without the interstate commerce piece to
it it is a tall order so this franchise
model was the Compromise from that thank
you any further questions from committee
members seeing none I'll next Call On
The Honorable Dr Joe
Hannon good morning and thank you
members of the committee uh my name name
is Joe Hannon uh I'm a former legislator
and I was also on the uh uh the study
commission back in
2018 as and I've been working on this
issue uh for quite a while with uh
several people who put forth the
legislation in the last few years uh
there's there's a lot of things I'd like
to to say but I know time is limited so
I'll try to keep it brief um that we
heard about the state model and why it's
successful and why it works and why
people some people think that it needs
to be that way for
cannabis uh prohibition from of alcohol
is is what led to the state liquor
commissions even being allowed when
prohibition was repealed the 21st
amendment gave States the sole power to
regulate uh Commerce and in and within
their states and they can take complete
control it's the one thing the federal
government gave the authority to the
states to do as far as Commerce we can't
say oh we're going to be the only ones
that sell Tomatoes we're the only ones
that sell tires we're not allowed to do
that it's only allowed because the 21st
amendment to the Constitution gives the
state the expressed authority to do so
so um we hear that one of the reasons
why the state didn't have state stores
because it's just a better compromise it
would mean that the state would be
directly selling an illegal federally
illegal substance every other state that
has done this has pretty much gone uh
with a a different model and that's what
we're trying to do with the original
bill that was passed um in the
house uh there were a couple other
things that I wanted to bring up um this
you know every time that I see a bill if
I wasn't sure if we should do it or not
one is it effective is it allowed um and
does it make uh does it solve a problem
uh there's nothing in this amendment
that can't be done through a franchise
model this the model that you've seen if
the governor and other people in the
Senate would like uh certain controls
they can get them through the model that
was put forth and passed in the last
committee and by the whole house uh the
state constitution I'm not going to read
all the articles but I I you know I'd
like for everyone wanted to go peruse
them if they haven't memorized them I'm
sure some of you have um basically we
have natural rights all men have certain
natural essential inherent rights among
them which are enjoying the defending
and defending life and Liberty acquiring
possessing and protecting property and
in a word of seeking and obtaining
happiness um we're allow we have a right
to privacy article 2B and's right to
live free from governmental intrusion
and private or personal information is
natural essential and
inherent
um there's a couple of prisions
Provisions in this amendment that uh I
think are are going to be a problem one
is the uh anti- lobbying provision for
the franchises the explanation for that
is well they have to sign a contract so
it's okay that we don't allow them to
petition the legislature for um their
industry their their livelihood uh the
state constitution in several places uh
says that everybody in New Hampshire has
a right to petition for redress of
grievances and also uh to petition the
legislature to educate them or to ask
them to do something everybody has that
right there are multiple times in the
state constitution where that's
mentioned um I won't list them all but
Article 28 14 22 30 and 32 are all
articles in the State Constitution that
contradict that part of this so if you
don't change anything else I think
that's something that needs to be
addressed I think it's in there and we
heard someone say this just recently and
someone just came up and said that we
have to pass this because it's the one
thing that can pass and I know that
you're all very uh you know honorable
educated people in here and I when I was
a representative I never ever wanted to
vote to pass something just because
that's the only thing we can pass what
should you pass and I think that's the
question we have to ask ourselves I'm
not going to read the statement of
principles from the nhgop platform but
it's uh it's kind of scary when you read
the list and think this bill is being
put forth and other people people in my
party are going to vote for it because
um there's nothing in our statement of
principles that really makes sense with
this this amendment um you know uh Free
People free markets free
enterprise um you know less government
intrusion less regulations Less business
uh barriers to enter businesses uh the
amendment that will be brought forth
later I believe is going to have um you
know more lower entry fees lower tiers
for people that do smaller craft uh
growing or or whatnot so I think that
there are so many reasons and I and I
can keep going but I know there's a lot
of people like to speak so I just
suggest that people go back read the
State Constitution and read all the
things that are that are in this list I
know uh you know Karen O ke from
marijuana policy project sent sent you
all list of all the you know this bill
the M the the uh the regular amendment
that was passed this amendment and they
have suggested amendments and then if
you go through that list and look at the
Constitution and the statement of
principles there's a lot of things that
don't don't don't make any sense
whatsoever so I I really ask you to
please um take the time to deliberate
tomorrow and and later in the week or
next week or two and um pass a bill that
makes sense and guarantees freedom
business free enterprise and still
protects people in the state there's
nothing in the other in the in the bill
that was passed already and by one one
committee that doesn't do almost
everything the governor wants except for
a couple little things that are
blatantly unconstitutional or go against
our statement of principles for from the
party that I belong to and I believe
that that's something that every party
should actually believe so thank you
thank
you our next call on Dr Riley
Kirk yeah make sure there it is done
okay thank you good morning and thank
you members of the committee my name is
Dr Riley Kirk I hold a PhD in
pharmaceutical sciences and I'm a
cannabis researcher and educator I'm a
resident of New Hampshire a hemp license
holder a member of NH can Advisory Board
and a daily cannabis consumer today I'm
speaking to express my concerns with um
1633 amendment I personally work with
marginalized communities that rely on
medical cannabis to help their symptoms
whether that be for chronic pain cancer
insomnia or other reasons many members
of this Community struggle financially
to get their medicine because it is not
covered by health insurance as almost
all other accepted medicines are note
regardless if you believe cannabis is a
medicine or not we have over 40,000
peer-reviewed Publications and I believe
it is objectively a medicine patients
are paying for their medicine out of
pocket and they need all the assistance
they can get the proposed amendment
would increase the price of cannabis
products for medical patients by
imparting a 12.5% tax this is not only
unnecessary because medical patients
make up a significantly lower portion of
the population compared to the adult use
Market but is also unnecessary in
targeting a vulnerable population in New
Hampshire that we should be protecting
the only way that I see this as a
feasible rout route forward is if we
provide medical patients with the right
to homow allowing them to have
affordable and accessible Avenue to
Quality cannabis products and grow them
to their specific needs additionally in
relation to the alternative treatment
centers these facilities have
established a community of trust with
their patients and Community they were
able to provide medicine education and
Community when no other place in the
state allowed access to this medicinal
plant purposely limiting The
Establishment for the sake of State
funds is egregious in my opinion we
should be prioritizing implementing what
the atcs have learned from doing
business in New Hampshire and use their
leadership as an example for patient
focused medicine and prioritize them in
their patients as legislation moves
forward myself and many other members of
the Cannabis Community were excited to
have an industry in the state but while
reading the proposed amendment including
page 15 line 15 which says that there is
a prerequisite of operating a cannabis
establishment in another state as a
criteria for granting licenses for
franchise models combined with the
lenient res residency requirements to me
this is essentially asking people in
neighboring states like Massachusetts
who on average make significantly more
money than New Hampshire residents to
continue taking opportunities away from
us we would have loved to have
experience in the canabus industry in
the State running businesses but our
state did not allow us to and we should
not be reprimanded because are loyal to
our community and our state this
proposed model emphasizes large
corporations and discourages small craft
businesses which is the opposite of what
we preach in our constitution lastly
increasing penalties for consumption of
cannabis in public does not make any
sense to me it is clear discrimination
against cannabis consumers and it makes
no sense to increase access availability
and education but also increase
punishments for using the same medicine
I hope to see um as we move forward that
we prioritize culture community and
quality of medicine for adult youth
consumers and for medical patients thank
you for your time thank you for your
testimony any questions from the
committee seeing none I'll next call on
Alicia Preston from Hampton New
Hampshire who puts down the unusual time
needed to speak of 30 seconds thank you
very much you're welcome
already yes thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
Alicia Preston I represent Brett Scott
of Brett Scott Enterprises he is New
Hampshire res president who owns several
businesses in New Hampshire and in
addition he owns retail Cannabis stores
in Maine he very much wanted to be here
today but he is not feeling well and
didn't want to contaminate you all so on
his behalf I'm speaking in favor of the
Maguire Amendment we believe it is a
workable model and most importantly one
that can actually be enacted into law
since he can't be here he is the expert
on details of the industry so he has or
will be emailing you all written
testimony thank you appreciate your
brevity
next call in Michelle Merritt for three
minutes new
Futures thank you Mr chairman honorable
members of the committee my name is
Michelle Merritt I'm the president at
new Futures many of you are familiar
with our organization we're here quite
often um today I also representing the
New Hampshire cannabis policy Coalition
for Public Health and Social Justice um
this is a group of aligned nonprofit
organizations who share the belief that
New Hampshire if New Hampshire moves in
the direction of commercializing uh
recreational Cannabis that policy makers
must utilize the best available science
and evidence to reduce public harm limit
Youth and problematic use and purposely
Advanced equity in this state for these
reasons the policy Coalition um came
together around a common set of
principles and they are to protect
Children and Youth promote social
justice and opportunities for Equity
protect public health and population
health and ensure appropriate funding
for cannabis revenue is directed towards
efforts that reduce the public harms
associated with use so it's this last
particular principle that I'm going to
touch on briefly I'm going to keep it to
three minutes um we are pleased to see
that this amendment creates a substance
abuse prevention treatment and Recovery
Fund um however it only allocates 10% of
the revenues to this fund according to
estimates from from policy makers and
legislators who have done work on this
issue for years this is likely going to
result in only a few million dollars
that would be designated to increase um
treatment needs in the state of New
Hampshire that is not enough um we urge
the committee to please consider
increasing that debt is consistent with
the recommendation that was made by the
study commission who worked on this
issue over the summer uh and into the
fall um our Behavioral Health System is
fragile in this moment and if we are
going to respond to Growing need for
services we need to make sure the funds
and the revenues are there to support
that system the last principle that I
just quickly wish to touch on is around
social justice um it was mentioned by a
previous speaker but we share the
concerns around how the penalties for
smoking in public are assessed under
this amendment under the current
decriminalization law if someone is
caught smoking in public with less than
three fifths uh I'm sorry 34s of an
ounce of cannabis the highest penalty
that they would face case for a third
offense is a Class B misdemeanor and a
fine of up to
$1,200 this is a serious criminal
penalty that um creates a record and
also includes a substantial fine however
under the proposed amendment New
Hampshire would be opening the door to
putting people in jail for up to a year
for a second Offense for this exact same
conduct um it's also punishable under as
an undefined misdemeanor we raised this
point before the committee for
consideration because it has the
potential to be extremely costly to New
Hampshire and also to New Hampshire
taxpayers who will have to pay for
public defenders for in any any
individual who is charged with a Class A
misdemeanor um the state would be ending
up having to foot the bill for this um
so for these reasons we ask the
committee if you are so inclined to pass
HB
1633 and the non- gerain amendment
that's before you today to please
consider increasing the amount that's
designated for substance abuse treatment
as well as addressing the issues and
problems that are within the amendment
around criminal penalties and align it
under the existing law I am happy to
take questions we also submitted
testimony through the online portal um
which also includes some suggested
revisions for language thank you
questions from the committee seeing none
next call on Jean Jonas from Wilton New
Hampshire
hi I'm uh kind of a pit pinch hitter
today uh Jim Riddle uh a New Hampshire
resident asked me to read this the uh
for him because he couldn't be here
today that was a a four-page letter and
I think no I got a one pager I did it
good good we all we all have the
four-page letter i time myself last
night at the kitchen table it took three
minutes so here we go thank you hi my
name is Jim Riddle I own and operate a
USDA license 's temp seed operation and
have a New Hampshire medical cannabis
card I serve on the Advisory Board of
the New Hampshire cannabis Association
and on the policy and Ed Committee of
new NOA New Hampshire I attended most of
the New Hampshire cannabis commission
hearings as well as meetings of the
house Commerce and finance committees
regarding cannabis legislation I have
submitted uh detailed written comments
and not able to testify today so I'm
here doing
it Mr chair and members of the committee
hp1 1633 as adopted by the house and
amended by uh rep Lon would establish a
tightly regulated free enterprise system
which protects Public Health prevents
sales of cannabis to miners yet provides
opportunities for Farmers entrepreneurs
and small businesses to enter the market
on the other hand uh rep Maguire's
non-gain Amendment submitted on behalf
of uh Senator Senator abbis represents a
big government takeover of New
Hampshire's cannabis Market without
including statutory language authorizing
the state to become a cannabis
franchiser the Amendments attempt to
establish a state cannabis cartel where
The Liquor Commission would control the
prices packaging labeling promotion
advertising location and even the sale
of property of cannabis
establishments the amendment would have
would pave the way for vertically
integrated operations where only the
manager of the operation would need to
be a resident of New
Hampshire the amendment provides no
pathway for alternative treatment
centers to become cannabis retail stores
it would po impose a 12 1 12% tax on the
sale of medical cannabis while providing
a 10% pay raise to Liquor Commission
employees and administrators to set up
the Cannabis
cartel plus the overall claim that
cannabis would be regulated like alcohol
is totally false as detailed in my
written comments as a hemp licensed hemp
grower I'm concerned that the amendment
would require all licensed hemp
operations in New Hampshire to cease
operation since we would no longer have
access to seeds which would be defined
and regulated as cannabis under the
amendment with an appropriation request
of almost 19 million over two years the
amendment is more than twice as
expensive as the 8 million requested to
implement hp1
1633 in the fall of
2023 NH can worked with New Hampshire
Farm Bureau NOA New Hampshire New
Hampshire uh herbal Association to
conduct a grower survey to determine the
level of support for legal cannabis
among Granite State farmers of which I
am
one the survey found that 87% of
respondents that currently
support uh currently Farm support the
legislation of adult use cannabis 78% of
those New Hampshire farmers expressed
interest in becoming licensed Growers
only 10% of farmers surveyed support a
state Monopoly system I urge the finance
committee to reject rep Maguire's
Amendment and pass hb1 1633 as adopted
by the house and amended by uh
representative Lyon thank you thank
you and I don't think we should subject
him to question since he's representing
someone else our next call on Matt Simon
also three
minutes thank you Mr chairman honorable
committee appreciate the opportunity to
speak on this amendment my name is Matt
Simon I live in nashwa I work for
granite Leaf cannabis
formerly Prime ATC we are one of the
three uh medical cannabis companies that
is licensed by the Department of Health
and Human Services we operate two
dispensaries one in Chichester one in
marac and we have a cultivation facility
in Peterborough we've been operating a
little over seven years uh providing
services to therapeutic cannabis
patients which now number uh slightly
over
14,000 in our state so we are a
nonprofit
we are solely focused on New Hampshire
uh we do not have any connections with
large companies and other states Etc so
we support legalization unfortunately we
cannot support this amendment as
currently written um to be clear we
would be willing to go along with all of
the requirements that have been clearly
stated by the governor on this issue
some of them we don't necessarily agree
with but we're willing to live with them
uh really appreciated the governor's
statement that the top priority for
cannabis legalization should be harm
reduction not profits uh we believe that
our program does serve a harm reduction
function in New Hampshire I won't go
into details on that I'll be here
tomorrow and I'll be happy to talk about
anything you might like to to talk about
but in this case I'm pleased to hear
representative Maguire say that this
amendment will not pass as is that it
will receive further work in this
committee I think that's great because
definitely needs more work and I don't
believe that it would go the whole way
if it doesn't receive more work so I
have passed out written testimony for
those of you who are on division one
you've already received these documents
via email the only change is that I
added the amendment number so if you've
already read it it's still the same if
you haven't here it is again there's a
onepage side by side that lays out four
issues that are most important from the
therapeutic cannabis perspective
big picture we want to have a program
that aligns and integrates the
therapeutic cannabis program with the
adult use stores the vision for the
franchise model as I understand it is
that patients could buy cannabis at the
franchise stores which I think would be
great it would expand access Statewide
Statewide it's access is currently
limited to seven dispensary locations so
it would be great for patients if we can
explain that unfortunately the amendment
is completely silent on how those sales
are supposed to take place how they're
to be regulated there needs to be
integration with the current program for
that to work at all so I I don't want to
sit here and talk I'll definitely not
exceed my three minutes I'm happy to
answer questions I'll be here tomorrow
thank you very much for your time and
attention thank
you seeing no questions I have uh four
more pink cards to speak some of them
three to five minutes five minutes 6 to
7 minutes 10
minutes coming up against my hard stop I
want to reduce all those times to about
3 and a half minutes so we will be
finished by 1:30 and you won't deny
otherwise I will have to recess this
till next Monday be finished by 12:30
12:30 is the hard stop as I said what
did I say 1:30 no we're back in here at
1 all right next call Holly
Stevens and Nami New Hampshire
and I will try to be be as brief as
possible um chairman while are members
of the committee my name is Holly
Stevens I'm the director of public
policy at Nami New Hampshire um Nami New
Hampshire is a nonprofit Grassroots
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people affected by
mental illness and suicide through
support Advocate advocacy and education
and I'm here to today just to speak um
to the amendment but we're not taking a
position either way on the amendment or
the bill uh at this point um just a
couple of points that Research indicates
that people with mental illness report
using marijuana at a rate of at least
twice that of people without mental
illness there's documented correlation
between cannabis use and the onset of
schizophrenia and other psychotic
disorders and especially in Young Folks
um who start using in either their teen
late teens or early 20s and for young
adults in particular cannabis use cont
can contribute to symptoms of mood
disorder anxiety and psychosis and may
Hassen the emergence of these disorders
um and and because of that uh we are
here today just to talk about um you
know the responsibility around this bill
and what New Hampshire needs to do and
put in place to make sure that we as
Michelle Meritt um mentioned reduce the
harms as much as possible um just a
couple of things um we also support
increasing the allocation to the
substance use prevention and treatment
Recovery Fund to a minimum of 20% but
we're also um suggesting that there be a
requirement that 50% of those funds be
allocated to the use of mental health
prevention treatment and recovery and
that's mental health treatment whether
it is co-occurring or not co-occurring
with a substance use disorder um we know
that some of these folks try marijuana
one and then they have psychosis and so
therefore we want to make sure that
there is some funding available to
assist the Community Mental Health
Centers and the hospitals with treating
these folks um and then the other
suggestion that we had um is that
there's language in the amendment um
that talks about uh funding being used
just for co-occurring disorders and we
have a suggestion that that be changed
in the written testimony I have a
suggestion on the back so when you
receive that you can take a look at that
and um with that um I will just take any
questions that you may have thank
you seeing no question representative
hle yes thank you um the studies that
you mentioned is it a correlation or is
there a causation at the at the root
level what we're with the study that we
recently read it's a
causation thank you and written test
morning if you give it to the
legislative budget assistant he'll see
that we all get copy he already has it
thank you thank you very
much next call on Michael
mlin uh please uh Sanctuary ATC please
keep it to three minutes thank
you good morning Mr chairman members of
community name is Mike mlof represent
Sanu arec and I will not try to Echo the
comments of Matt Simon will point out a
couple of things uh and Hampshire is in
the marijuana sales business it has been
for seven years it has been with seven
different locations throughout the state
selling therapeutic products very
successfully uh the bills we see today
and the amendment seem to look at
creation of something that doesn't exist
it does exist and the New Hampshire ATC
should be
involved uh this amendment today from
represent Maguire in one of the early
paragraphs points out that an
alternative treatment center shall not
hold a retail license to sell cannabis
products yet later in the same Amendment
they ask the alternative treatment
centers to sell their products to
franchise retail outlets so they're
basically asking us to sell to the
competition and help put us out of
business when a when a state
incorporates retail sales into uh a
therapeutic Market there's a traditional
30 40% drop in activity so this
amendment basically
says uh keep working as a therapeutic
center give your products to other
people as you watch your business
decline it just is
nonsensical in addition further on in
the amendment they talk about how being
an alternative treatment center should
allow you to have a oneup on getting a
license uh so we'll work on this
hopefully in the committee but it just
you're looking at a business that's
existed in the state selling therapeutic
marijuana products successfully that's
now being asked in this amendment to
stay out of the business that they know
best and that's how I will end my
remarks thank you for cutting through
all that thank you any questions I'll be
happy any questions seeing
none next call on Daryl Ames I have the
next two cards one is New Hampshire
cannabis Association the other one is
New Hampshire cannabis party he will
tell us what's the difference between
those two groups thank you uh my name is
darl eem I'm the founder of the New
Hampshire cannabis Association and in my
duties the last six years I've been
speaking with residents in governmental
and non-governmental organizations all
throughout the state I speak with
associations all around the country and
in my professional uh duties I as a
consultant in the space I speak with
hundreds of operators every year all
around the country and the one thing I
want to kind of say today is that we we
oppose this amendment because structures
matter and what the real balance of what
we're you're being asked to do is to uh
balance the state's direct involvement
in plant touching activities against um
Federal intervention along with Public
Safety the uh health of the atcs and a
structure and foundation for an industry
where they can The Operators can be
successful and to the representative's
question about that the franchise model
actually lowers the bar for federal
Intervention when you have uh on one
side traditional models that that seek
to insulate the state by limiting their
exposure to plant touching activities on
the other end of that Spectrum you have
state run stores where you are the
business and in the middle you have a
franchise and agency model uh the state
run stores is kind of a nebulous thre
threat from the federal government if
they decide some agency somewhere could
come and take action uh if you're a
franchise you are putting the state of
New Hampshire directly under the purview
of the Federal Trade Commission and the
federal franchise regulations which
means in theory a potential that if a
franchisee decided that they were being
treated unfairly they could Lodge a
complaint with the FTC and if the FTC
finds it has Merit they could launch a
federal investigation into the state of
New Hampshire that's very concrete but
let's just talk about the how the vision
of these structures play out in reality
HB 1633 is the culmination of many years
and dozens of people working on a bill
to try and balance these requirements in
contrast the amendment reads like it was
written by a handful of people for one
person so let's walk through some of
this so HB 1633 provides flexibility and
pricing to balance supply and demand
signals in the market so retailers can
stay competitive the other states not
that the commission can simply consult
on price but rather that the commission
has and I quote the final authority to
set the price of all cannabis products
sold in a retail store in the private
Market we call this price fixing one
bill understands that vertically
integrated companies may want to co
collocate cultivation or manufacturing
with retail if allowed in their mun
municipality to reduce cost and risk the
other actually forbids retail
collocation entirely even if it's legal
one bill believes medical patient
shouldn't be burden with paying another
12 a half% the amendment believes that
that's perfectly acceptable one bill of
used The Advisory Board as an an asset
to help these new operators uh with
things like education and funding and
act as a conduit for communication on
what is and isn't working to the
commission the other reads like a Liquor
Commission Advisory Board they let's
take a peek at it they have the chair of
the Li commission I'm pretty sure the
Liquor Commission talks to The Liquor
Commission they've got the president of
the associations of chiefs of police uh
some random member of the public
appointed by the governor a state
senator and State Rep these are all
people who can talk to the commission
currently and and that's it it's going
to set it up as a politicized adversary
to the industry on top of the Liquor
Commission and their
regulation uh one bill provides clear
legislative intent to ensure our medical
cannabis industry has a path to survival
the other creates a high risk that our
medical industry will crumble one bill
allows municipalities in partnership
with private owners to determine their
location one bill puts that decision
solely up to the commission end up
choosing a location that doesn't work
too bad you're not going to have the
right to move without uh approval even
if you're working with an opted in
municipality one bill understands the
size nature and Le of the facilities is
a consideration for the private owner in
the municipality the other one the
Liquor Commission will will basically
stipulate what your layout is one bill
Embraces the Nuance of lands that are
both public and private and strikes a
balance if you own land that that has
incurred use is that public or private
well the other bill doesn't even
approach that one bill slightly
increases the penalties for public
consumption we've heard this amendment
really ramps it up even more uh one the
amendment also declares the commission
shall have the primary responsibility
for enforcement of all cannabis laws
including any trafficking uh quote from
an article in the last several years
Chinese backed marijuana operations have
cropped up across the United States
including major drug bus in New Mexico
in Maine in Maine alone border patrol
has reportedly identified at least 270
illegal marijuana grow operations
throughout the state I'm very concerned
that they might not have the
capabilities to handle that the
amendment envisions the commission have
a primary responsibility enforcement of
all cannabis laws I saw nothing in the
amendment of whether they have to
actually notify any jurisdictions
they're going into the amendment also
provides that that 10% uh bonus in the
private sector you might hire more
people you might have something that's
more goal- based they're just saying
here's 10% for for coming in working on
this the vision of this amendment really
strikes me as something for the wealthy
and the connected all right if I were
setting the stage for something like
that that's probably exactly the bill
that I would that I would write um and I
would say you know there's risk in any
industry there's going to be a
consolidation right a ramp up a
consolidation in an evening um and can
you finish yes I can and I would say
this as the last thing um representative
Maguire mentioned last week that he who
cares the least has the most power and I
there's some definite wisdom in that I
would just say that some of us care
enough that it's better to see a good
bill die than it is to see a bad bill
become law this amendment should never
see the light of day out of this
committee and neither should the
franchise model I thank you and I will
answer any questions you have thank you
any questions from committee members
seeing none the last person I'll call on
it I believe it's Nathaniel guran uh New
Hampshire cannabis
party did I pronounce your name
correctly you did thank
you honorable committee honorable
committee chair members of the House
finance committee thank you for the
opportunity to share my perspectives on
the matter before us I am currently
chair of the New Hampshire cannabis
party who endorses candidates for State
office who support Common Sense cannabis
legalization I am also a regular monthly
col columnist for the Conway Daily Sun
covering the New Hampshire campaign for
cannabis legalization and CEO of fincan
an industry Pioneer since
2015 in the field of cannabis banking
payments oh that's that's a lot better
payments Financial services and uh
related compliance issues not
withstanding the dangers of the proposed
cannabis franchise model which I will
Briefly summarize the non- gerain
amendment before us is nothing more than
a corrupt and cynical political zombie
Trojan Horse it's designed and intended
to fail and to blow up in our faces I am
not going to detail here and now why and
how this is the case but for those who
are interested in the underlying
political motivation of promoting this
model to the exclusion of Common Sense
cannabis legal ization and who have not
yet read my column cannabis and
hamburgers a copy is included in today's
handout for your convenience be reminded
that everyone here and All State Rep
Senators executive counselors Liquor
Commission leadership State AGS and
governor's office and other Stak holders
have not only already received a copy of
this column but have also been
officially notified last November of the
lack of legal viability and extreme
dangers of enacting and implementing the
propo this proposed cannabis franchise
model
I have also included in today's handout
a copy of that email notice including a
list of all its recipients so no one can
claim ignorance as a defense you'll also
note find in the package an excerpted
copy of a legal white paper authored by
Karen O'Keefe an attorney and director
of State policies for the national
cannabis advocacy group marijuana policy
project which provides referenced and
additional details on the risks of
non-implementation due to federal law
and of high possible Financial costs to
New Hampshire due to to vulnerability to
litigation cannabis is currently a
federally illegal and prohibited DEA
schedule one controlled substance and
its possession use and commerce is
considered criminal activity a criminal
Enterprise cannot offer franchises of
its business
model claiming not to be directly
involved in the business of selling
cannabis because one is merely a
franchisor is as utterly ridiculous as
McDonald's claiming it's not in the
business of selling hamburgers because
it has franchisees it is quite possible
a court could find that the state
franchising Cannabis stores must entail
a conspiracy to sell cannabis in
violation of federal law or aiding and
abetting the sale of cannabis a court
could rule an agent setting up a
franchise cannot fulfill his obligation
under state law and simultaneously heed
the federal ban on Distributing
marijuana and that the law is thus
preempted if a state worker's job is to
sell cannabis the state would be
directing them to commit a federal crime
in 2017 a federal district court in
Massachusetts dismissed a RICO case
against the defendant Bank on grounds
that merely providing customary
Financial Services to a state Li State
LC albeit operating in violation of
federal law did not rise to the level of
Direction in and control of the
Enterprise to implicate Rico liability
as a codefendant this reasoning allows
states to regulate cannabis industry
operators as a customary government
function so long as they are not
substantially involved in the operation
and direction of the business itself
however the franchise model proposed by
The Liquor Commission Envision envisions
quite the opposite as they would be
enforcing strict standards in almost
every aspect of franchisee operations
Direction and practices enacting this
scheme could easily invite multiple Rico
based private litigations as well as
public prosecution the distinction may
seem puzzling but a legalizing and
regulating conduct is legally different
from the state entering into a
commercial relationship to commit
federal
crimes there are also burdens to being a
franchisor the commission and the state
as franchisor would be subject to
Federal jurisdiction penalties and
investigations the Federal Trade
commission's franchise rule imposes
obligations on franchise ores including
a 23p part legal disclosure the FTC
defines a franchise as any continuing
commercial relationship or Arrangement
whatever the name in which three
criteria are satisfied including the
franchise or will exert or has authority
to exert a significant degree of control
over the franchisees method of operation
or provide significant assistance to the
franchisees method of
operation a franchisor is not always
liable for the actions of a franchisee
the plaintiff must prove actual agency
or apparent agency but the level of
control and involvement envisioned by
the commission and its franchise model
makes it likely that a court could find
either type of agency even unsuccessful
litigation can be a significant
financial drain Andor delay program
implementation indefinitely with all of
the potential and likely civil and
criminal consequences of either a state
Monopoly or franchise model while
cannabis remains a federally controlled
and prohibited substance bear in mind
that enacting the proposed franchise
model would subject both the state with
its Deep Pockets as well as the elected
leadership and our state employees to
having an irresistible Target on their
backs that will attract potentially
endless meritorious as well as
opportunistic litigation can you finish
up
okay I will finish up um in short States
legalizing and regulating cannabis are
on solid legal ground while a state
operating a franchise to sell cannabis
is on shaky and potentially very
dangerous ground um hr1 1633 as amended
by the primary sponsor and as passed by
the house Commerce and and consumer
affairs committee and the Full House
conforms as much as is legally viable
with the Senate and Governor's
conditions for approval and I would urge
this committee to both reject the
pending uh Maguire Amendment and vote
OTP on hr1 1633 as amended as a sincere
first step towards implementing Common
Sense legalization thank you thank you
any anything from the committee I will
read the blue sheet for those that
signed in either Pro or
con and it looks like all the people
that signed in well Michael mlin is Con
Celeste Clark from Raymond is Con kale
McGuinn from Raymond is Con Ava Lyn from
Raymond is Con and Marissa
mcguin mcin from Raymond is Con those
are the people that signed in we have
uh input online that we'll be looking at
um our committee assistant will be
passing out all the copies that people
have passed in I appreciate the input
you've brought some new information to
us that we didn't have before that we
can use in our discussions of of these
bills on 1633 they'll be in division 1
tomorrow at 10 1 at 1:00 1: tomorrow
across the hall and uh thank you all for
your input um we're working for the good
of you all and want and I appreciate all
the inputs we've had I will now close
the hearing on the
um Amendment on
1633 thank you all um members we're
coming back at
1:00 anybody want to discuss some of the
stuff at 1:00 some of us will be having
lunch in the back room
so then we'll start promptly at 1:00
we've got 10
B
e
committee exec session we have 10 bills
have some people missing that I try to
accommodate
so what I'll do is take up the bills
that were non-controversial
first if the committee will indulge so
we won't have we'll get through those
quickly and and know we're done with
those
and so that's what I want to do until
whoever gone to the Senate can get back
on time
so we have everybody here so first one I
have that's at 9 to Z is in division one
house bill
1666 thank you Mr representative lean
thank you Mr chairman 1666 relative to
income reporting requirements for
lobbyists and I'd like to recognize
representative Sweeny for a motion thank
you Mr chairman I would move a to pass
on 16 19 66 and I'd like to speak to my
motion you're recognized thank you Mr
chairman uh this is a very simple Bill a
second thank you got him in my ear
oh uh this bill requires lobbyists to
identify clients and income received
from lobbying activity it also
authorizes the Secretary of State to
enforce lobbyist statement requirements
uh there's really no true large fiscal
impact to this bill I actually think we
as a division spent two seconds on it um
so it was uh pretty straightforward nine
to zero thank you Karen will you the
second okay thank you further discussion
on Senate Bill
1666 how house bill Senate House Bill
1666 is there any further
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call a rooll for the motion of ought to
pass on House Bill
1666 thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth yes representative
Maguire he's not here he's not here
representative Petri votes
yes representative Emer
yes representative Griffin
yes representative Mooney
yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean
yes representative hle
yes representative Sweeney yes
representative Camal yes representative
papichi wer
yes representative walner
yes uh representative Lehman yes
representative buo yes representative
uitt he's not here okay represent Heath
yes representative Murray yes yes
representative eil yes representative
torski
yes representative haen Phillips
yes representative Stringham yes
representa grassy
yes representative priest yes
representative wer yes Mr chairman the
vote is 23 to Z in favor of the
motion okay we have adopted the report
on house 1666 23 to
zero
and representative Sweeny have you got
the report all
set thank you very much it's not
consent and um was there money in
this I suppose we'll put it on the
regular calendar
then all right the next one that's 9 to
Z is in division two
and that's uh House Bill 1570 I believe
we're getting
a an amendment passed
out and I'll recognize representa emmer
to explain
it thank you Mr chair I would recognize
representative mu for a
motion thank you I'd like to make the
motion of um are we looking for an
amendment motion or
a we've been passed an amendment I think
we got to pass the amendment first sorry
so I'd like to uh make a motion to adopt
Amendment 1037 H to HB
1570 is there a second
second and I can speak to the amendment
all right you're recognized uh the this
bill came to us with a $5 million price
tag
in order to go out and take a physical
inventory of of all the school buildings
in the
State uh we decided uh maybe we don't
want to spend $5 million on this right
about now midterm uh because it sounds
more like a budgeted item so we took the
money out but we wanted to give some
ability for the Department of Education
to continue to go down this path because
it was a general consensus it's not a
bad idea
however without any money they they
really can't do the work because the
idea is to hire a consultant and we have
33,000 square feet I it's a lot of
square feet and you pay so much per
square foot for all these
evaluations so what what this amendment
does is we we decided that the
Department of Education should be able
to go to fiscal committee and request
funds once they have a contract or RFP
out and some replies back and do it the
right way uh so what the but they didn't
have the ability to go the fiscal
committee so what the amendment does the
uh Amendment uh
137h it gives the Department of
Education the ability to go to fiscal
committee and ask for money that's all
it does it's so it's not changing the
idea that we're not going to fund it
it's changing the idea that they can go
get funds as they move down the
road
so that's the motion on the
amendment any further
discussion any uh can we do this by show
of
hands all in favor of adopting Amendment
1037 raise your
hand anyone
opposed motion is
adopted next
motion
otpa who will make that thank you if I
may uh Mr chair I'd like to make the
otps otpa motion for hb1
1570 okay papichi Mueller and second
second is
Emme further discussion seeing none
click will call the role ought to pass
as amended by Amendment 1037 on house
Bill
1570 thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth
yes representative uh Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes representative
Sweeney
yes representative C
yes representative papichi Muller yes
representative
walner
yes representative Lehman yes
representative Buco yes representative U
they're still not here representative
Heath
yes represent Murray yes represent evil
yes represent torski
yes representative haken Phillips yes
representa Stringham yes represent
grassy yes represent priest
yes represent wer yes Mr chairman a vote
is 23 to Zer in favor of the motion okay
and have you got your blurb almost ready
okay was
Popich
papichi all right Mr chairman this has
no money in it all right let's put this
in the in the um consent calendar
then
okay all right the next one that's a N9
to zero is in division
three representative Mr Mr Ripple is
handing out the amendment
now
so
so representative
pole would you do you have a motion that
you want to make on Amendment
1186 uh to HB 1282 and then we'll
discuss
it sure I move that we adopt Amendment
1186 H to
Second all right Motion in a second to
adopt Amendment 1186 we all have it
before us changing the effective date
what did it change it from uh it was in
the current fiscal year we just bounced
it out to where this would be
incorporated in the next budget
cycle okay any further
discussion represent priest you have
your light on did you want to say
something okay thank you all right I
don't see any other lights um let's have
a hand vote on accepting Amendment 1186
H all in favor raise your
hand hands down any opposed the motion
is adopted next
motion representative
hle representative
hle and the second second representative
Edwards okay
motion before us
is for House Bill 1282 relative to the
duration of child support the motion is
ought to pass as amended by Amendment 11
1186 Amendment 1186
H further discussion uh yes may I sir
sir uh so uh this this bill uh was
pretty non-controversial this came out
of uh the committee uh the the policy
committee 13 to nothing and um and
passed easily in the house it closes a
loophole in cases where a child turns 18
while in school uh but then does not
graduate U so this this would allow
their social security benefits um to be
managed in a way that's consistent with
the duration of the child support and
close the
loophole this uh was recommended for uh
passage 9 Nothing by division 3
thank you any further
discussion seeing none the motion before
us is ought to pass as amended House
Bill 1282 as amended by Amendment
1186 there's no further discussion the
clerk will call the rooll on that motion
thank you Mr chairman representative ER
yes representative Petri votes yes
representative Emerich yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Moy yes representative
Edwards yes representative beanie yes
representative H yes representative
Sweeney yes representative camell yes
representative Popovich Muller yes
representative walner yes representative
Lehman yes representative buo yes
representative
U still not here son of
a yes that was gun that was not
representative Heath yes and she jumped
a gun on me son of a gun um
representative Murray
yes representative evil yes
representative torki yes representative
haken Phillips yes representative
Stringham yes representative grassy yes
representative priest yes representative
uh Wier yes Mr chair the vote is 23 to
nothing in favor of the motion okay 23
to nothing uh
what's
that and representative H do you have a
report
ready uh we'll get one okay before we
leave today does that have money uh can
this go on consent there's no money
spent in this
budget but it's in the it's in the but
it goes forward to the next someone
could argue that yes it spends money but
not now right okay so probably regular
calendar to avoid any okay we could
probably just do Pi on that the single
Pi y all right so that's so and and uh
committee members the likely effect of
what's been going on by the uh speaker
and the clerk is that probably all the
finance bills will end up maybe on April
11th like 41
bills so
punishment the the uh procedure I'd like
to follow is like what they were doing
with election
law just having piis and of course these
bills we're doing now that are
non-controversial they may not even have
discussions if they come 23 to Z or 25
to Z on a recommendation I expect the
speaker will just say all in favor say I
so
question I just wondered if that I
understand that you want to do just pis
but on some of these more complex bills
don't you think that we should have more
discussion with the full
house if if I can't get pis on all of
them then we it'll be what it'll be but
I think the whole house would appreciate
it if there's 41 bills from finance that
we do something to expedite them so I'll
I'll try to anyone that that wants to do
something more uh extensive please let
me know so I'll I'll at least give the
clerk and this and the speaker some
warning that's some of them I'm going to
take a little longer but I'm hopeful
that I'm hopeful the majority of them
can be quick when we have that many
bills that people will say oh you people
from Finance you like
education we don't want that at
reputation so so give to give you a
heads up sir I expect 1573 is going to
require a
debate I expect you're
right and and some of those I know we
can't avoid it but if we can expedite
a pretty good portion of our input that
uh the rest of the members of the house
will be grateful so that's my hope as
well as us we don't want to be there
till 10:00 that night either but if all
our bills end up in a calendar with
dozens of others but the reason for that
is most of the second committee bills
have a
longer um deadline so they'll liable to
be a lot at the end we may be in with a
bunch of others so just a warning I want
to I want to hope to we can um
accomplish
so hope for your cooperation thank you
all right the next one uh I think we're
going we've got the uh three that we had
nine to
zero and division three you have any you
have uh
1564 1564 was five to one all right I
guess that was
not well attended but
uh um all right 1564 it's on the back of
the page in division
three so representative Mooney do you
have a motion yes thank you Mr chairman
I would like to move ought to pass on
house spill 1564 and I can speak to that
motion I'll second
all right and you are recognized thank
you very much House Bill 16 excuse me
1564 uh came out unanimously out of the
children and family law committee and
then further out of the Full House the
bill is a long time
incoming adjustments to the child
support guidelines were in need and the
sponsors of the bill spent an entire
summer meeting with Statewide
interested vested parties to those that
know child support guidelines best those
from the legal Community those from uh
those from the legislature those from
legal assistants those for who are uh
parents and so as a result of that this
bill was sponsored and so uh seeing as
though it is so uh well researched and
seeing as though it is so local you'll
hear about a competing bill later on
today but it is so local
to the state I I would recommend an
ought to
pass further
discussion uh it's a little it's a
little related um my my comment on this
is that uh
1564 was so well accepted that we passed
it pretty quickly and then what we did
was there was a second bill that was
very similar to it um uh 1595 and I I
won't speak that other than to say that
um a small amount of money gets spent in
1564 that same amount got repeated in
1595 but if we pass both bills we only
need one slice of the money and I think
that was what
$105,000 or something so it's pretty
pretty di Minimus so I I support 1564
and just want you to have a heads up
that $595 is H is pretty tightly related
okay and I see
tersi and priest made the Motions in in
the committee either of you want to have
anything further to
say thank you all right any further
discussion uh motion before us is ought
to pass on House Bill 1564 relative to
child support guidelines there's no
further discussion the clerk will call
the rooll on the motion of ought to pass
thank you Mr chairman representative Ur
yes
representative Petri votes
yes representative em
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
Representative hle
no representative Sweeney
yes representative cell
yes representative papichi Muller yes
representative walner
yes representative Lehman yes
representative buo yes representative VI
is still not
here representative Heath
yes representative Murray yes
representative evil
yes representative sori yes
representative haen Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative grassy yes representative
priest
yes representative Wier
yes Mr chairman the vote is 22 to1 in
favor of the
motion okay being 22 to1 the motion of a
to pass is adopted and we'll be looking
for that uh report from representative
Mooney who's probably got it written
already and I guess this spends money so
it'll be in regular calendar
okay so if you're looking for input I
think 1593 would be doable in this
circumstance okay and is this PRI and
tersi that are going to do the motion in
the uh
second I'll do the motion to autop pass
okay bring there there's an amendment
here isn't
there there was Finance Amendment
1161 not a new one
yeah you said 1593 right3
1593 this this this is the string of
Edwards
bill with so there's an
amendment oh there's a new
Amendment this
am didn't
they it's you well you don't have
1593 thank
you definitely
1570 I know but that's that's another
that's also before us but 1593 is the
one we have the motion on now you don't
have the
folder 49 what do you got here
when you
done okay we got one member back does
anyone know where representative huitt
is home he went home
okay we we can hang on to that until he
finds a folder I got we don't one 1573
okay
happens got
it
e
okay the bill before us now will be
House Bill
1593 make an appropriation of the
Department of Health and Human Services
to support recreation activities for
individuals with development
disabilities representative Stringham
has moved out to pass is there a
second
representative Heath is a
second and there is an amendment before
us second all right second we'll put
down representative Heath will you
second the amendment as well thank you
all right Amendment
1161 on House Bill 1593 does everyone
have
it
1161 all right representative Stringham
would you like to make some explanation
on the amendment uh yes this amendment
uh was presented before uh uh Finance
three and part of the the bill that we
passed uh basically uh the original bill
passed
17-3 uh in health and human services and
on a voice vote on the floor uh in uh
testimony uh before Finance 3 um uh we
uh changed the eligibility to just being
adults who are under the disability
waiver feeling that uh uh that children
had other opportunities for Community
recreational program uh the amendment
also requires the Department of Health
and Human Services to produce a timely
report so that adjustments to the
developmentally disabled program
could be included uh with the next bium
other than that the uh the base part of
the bill stays the
same
okay representative Edwards uh thank you
sir um this this bill uh passed OT uh
otpa out of the division 3 7 to3 uh 6
to3 rather and uh I've since I was one
of the Nays I've reconsidered my vote
and so if we were to revote in division
3 it would have been 72 I think I I
support the uh the stringam amendment
limiting this to the adult DD
Community thank
you further
discussion seeing none all in favor of
adopting and and what was the change to
1161 what was the effect of that just
the change of the the population has
served yes and the report and the report
okay
any further questions on Amendment
amendment is moved by representative
Stringham seconded by representative
Heath can we do it show of hands all in
favor hands down any opposed the motion
is adopted the next that amendment is
adopted the next motion is ought to pass
on House Bill 1593 as amended by
Amendment
11618 further discussion string I can
just speak briefly this bill was NE
necessitated by A disruption to the
developmental Services Program and it
was caused by an unannounced change in
the list of eligible Services during
this budget cycle individuals previously
rece receiving services like bowling
swimming and karate and other activities
that promote socialization with the
general public and help Advance health
and safety goals are no longer part of
the developmental disability Medicaid
waiver program uh so in essence these
people with the de developmental
Disability Services have had one element
of their support kind of taken out in
the middle of this budget
cycle after July 1st so this bill
provides a maximum of
$600 uh per person through the end of
the budget cycle prioritizing those who
participated in these programs under a
prior individualized service budget and
it would be effective upon Passage the
program still has an income and medical
necessity means test for any participate
participant the appropriation is
$500,000 uh but there are comparable
Savings in the budget under the
developmental disability waiver normally
these people would have received these
services for the full two years uh we
would have paid half of it out of the
general fund now we're talking about one
year and um uh paying for all of it out
of the general fund uh so this is a
one-time fix it goes away after the end
of this bium cycle um the the uh items
discussed in the amendment is to uh help
us you know rebuild the support stool
for the developmentally disabled uh and
uh um you find out exactly how these
services are being used what's being
requested and making appropriate changes
in the program uh so uh so this this
change instead of being chaos is
something a little more um smooth for
these people so I ask for your vote to
ought to pass on this okay motion is
ought to pass as amended by string
representative Stringham seconded by
representative Heath question from
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman um what makes this a one-time
expense and not ongoing won't the same
thing come up next year this dis
appropriation is at the end of it ends
and any unspent funds go away at the end
of the bium and uh uh there's no no
provision for continuing these
recreational services for these
individuals after the end of this panium
follow question so but I meant the need
you're going to think that next time
we'll need the same thing again yes no
well um you you know that part of the
reason why we're doing a report is to
find out exactly what services are being
requested how they're being used and um
and to contemplate whether some of them
uh can be can be refashioned in a way
that puts them back into the
developmental disability program or
whether we need to find something else
and uh work work closely with the
Department of Health and Human Services
and the disability Community to faret
that out uh but um you know I don't
think a long-term solution that involves
us paying uh all of these Services Under
the general fund is is what we're
looking to
do further discussion seeing none the
clerk will call the role on to pass as
amended House Bill
1593 as amended by Amendment 11
61h thank you Mr chairman representative
F yes representative McGuire yes
representative Petri volz representative
Emer yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean yes
Representative hle
no representative Sweeny
yes represent camell yes represent
pavich Muller yes represent walner yes
representative Lehman yes representative
buo yes representative huitt it's still
not here represent of Heath yes
represent of Murray yes yes represent
evil yes represent torki yes represent
haaken Phillips yes representative
Stringham yes representative grassy yes
representative priest yes representative
wer
yes Mr chairman the vote is 23 to1 in
favor of the
motion thank you we'll put it on the
regular calendar all right I guess we
have all the members now accounted
for
I appreciate you waiting for and
representative stringham's got the going
to have the report ready
shortly thank you all right moving now
back to division one and recognizing
representative Lehman for House Bill
1178 thank you Mr chairman House Bill
1178 relative to an employees unused
earn time I'd like to recognize
representative Maguire who also has an
amendment to offer yes thank you um I
I'd like to move Amendment 1326 H uh
which is on your table and this is
identical to the amendment we voted on
in committee it's just that um Amendment
1047 H was actually written by
representative infantine and had his
name on the top so this this is uh me
doing the same thing I was doing this
morning putting my name on something
somebody else somebody else's
work something I never did in school but
anyway
um second yes thank you so
um and so this is this is the amendment
that representative infantine who the
chair of the labor committee wanted to
um put before the house um when this
bill first came up but OS for some
reason neglected to draft it for him and
and so it didn't didn't happen so what
it does is um it it changes the um the
circumstances under which someone's um
earn time would get paid to them to the
just the circumstances of when the
company um uh he leaves employment when
the company uh closes or changes
ownership so um what representative
infantine is concerned about is that the
way the bill was originally written it
it uh over could override uh Union
contracts and other you know labor
agreements that um where this particular
issue is
already um already in those agreements
and so by doing this it's it's um
reducing the scope to cases where
essentially the company's going out of
business or or being sold so therefore
or such agreements would would not um uh
sort of would not apply and and in
particular representative infantine also
said that the previous the other version
of the bill the one that passed the
house has gone further in the process
and just been stopped dead every time so
this this is not the first time this has
come up this has come up years and years
and years so he thinks that with this
amendment this will get approval and
become law but without it it won't thank
you thank you questions representative
hle thank you Mr chair question from
someone on the
committee um some employers are moving
to New vacation time off models from the
traditional paid holidays paid time off
to something called Flex time off I
guess where it's not as as rigid in
accounted for how is that taken care of
in this
amendment so um you'll
see than yeah thank you for the question
but you'll see
um that the written policy so so line
15 um paid time off per the per the
employer's written policy so um this
allows the employer to actually have a
policy that that addresses this so I
think that's that's where um that would
that that would than come into
play representative Edward this is just
a technical clarification sir the the
the document that we're using to as a
table of contents lists amendment number
47h and the and the one the amendment I
have in front of me is 1326 I just want
to make sure I know which one I'm voting
on yes thank you so this is they they're
identical except
that at the top of 1047 H says
representative infantine at the top of
this it says representative Maguire and
and uh that's because technically we we
cannot pass an infantine amendment you
know so that's why it's there thank
you any further discussion on
representative grassy yes thank you Mr
chairman um what this amendment does is
it pretty much guts the bill this bill
um dealt with employees the bill deals
with with companies that have 15 or more
employees and it changes to 20 or more
employees at 15 or more employees that
exempts 84% of the businesses in the
state of New Hampshire so you know going
to 20 employees you know how many more
EMP how many more businesses is
affecting I'm not sure but the thing is
is that we're basically saying that
we're going to provide protections for
fewer workers and the most important
thing that this does is it takes out one
incident where an employee is separated
from their employer and that's being
laid
off and I can tell you from personal
experience that when a company lays you
off they may or may not have the intent
to rehire you but if you ACR your time
by the Personnel policy in January on
January 1 you acre your time and if the
layoff occurs as it did during covid on
March Mar
15th and somebody took all their
vacation an employee in the company took
all their vacation time in
February
that when March 15th hits the employees
who hadn't taken their vacation time
lose that vacation
time um unless the company comes back in
you know reopens very quickly um and and
the and the owner of the company is
willing to protect the benefits of that
employees they would lose their acred
time
and I think that this really is
something that affects more working
people than it does Executives or people
that work in high-tech where they have
Flex time uh this affects people who are
at the lower end of the pay scale and to
basically take time that they have
worked
for sometimes for
years and and and to say that's not
important and we're not going to protect
you um is is irresponsible i i you know
if we're going to if we're going to help
anybody our job should be able to help
those who struggle the hardest and this
is a bill that does protect them and the
amendment does not do that because it
takes that provision where you've been
laid off and it takes that right out and
I think there's you know if you're if
the business closes or changes hands
that's good if it if you're laid off or
if you leave on your own accord and you
in in favorable terms in the employee
you will many times get your ACR
vacation but if you're laid
off which is no fault of your own you
lose you can lose that time and this
would provide protection for it I have
an amendment which takes care of some of
the issues and caps the amount of time
that you can carry that that would be
carried to 30 days um we felt that this
was an amendment that would uh would
protect most people work most average
laborers don't get more than 30 days
vacation in a year so they'd have to
work there an awful long time to get
that uh so we felt that the another
amendment is more appropriate uh whereas
this amendment really takes away uh this
benefit to a large number of employees
who work very hard for the time that
they
acrew was there any discussion with the
Department of Labor when we were dealing
with this bill I recall some time ago
testimony by the Department of Labor
saying that when a business went out of
business they were the first ones there
to seize assets to ensure that the
employees got their last paycheck that
that was from when businesses go out of
business but when layoffs happen that
doesn't that doesn't happen I can tell
you that I know a business that they
laid off their employees it took a
number of years before they brought
everybody back everybody came back as a
new employee so everybody lost their
benefits lost all their vacation time
and everything and and the company did
not make that up you had a choice you
either went back to work for the company
or you didn't go back to work for the
company some people went back to work
for them some people had found other
jobs and didn't go back to work for them
but the thing is when you acrw time and
particularly if you've pet in you know
five or 10 years and you lose it that's
the tough and the thing is is that
they're saying well yeah you can go to
the Department of Labor and you can
complain but if you expect to get
rehired when the layoff ends and you
filed a labor grievance against their
company you just got moved to the bottom
of that list you're not going to get
rehired because you filed a grievance
against them so you know it it saying
that there is an opportunity most
employees if they liked their job are
not going toile an grievance they're
basically going to say you know I hope
the the company Honors that commitment
they made to me and when they bring me
back they'll give me my vacation time
and I'll be happy with that uh but that
doesn't happen and this law would
protect that
well I wonder if it overlaps what the
Department of Labor is already doing and
we didn't have any testimony from them
did we represent hle thank you Mr chair
um in the case of the employer wanting
to to make sure that employee comes back
because they're a valuable employee I
think if they went ahead and cut their
time and did not allocate it back to
them in some form of a paycheck right
you would disincentivize that person
from returning or being a productive Lo
person long term for the company and in
in many cases would encourage them by by
that type of act to move elsewhere to
another company so for the employees
that are that are valuable to the
companies I think this is a
non-issue further
discussion the motion before us is ought
to pass as amended
by Amendment hand on the
amendment yeah on the amendment
Amendment 132
26h on House Bill
1176 any objection to a hand
count seeing none all in favor of the
amendment raise your
hand
one is it
12 all right hands down
opposed
11 12 to 11 the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is by
representative Maguire seconded by
representative
Sweeney there 24 people
here yeah we missing one wait a minute
all
right maybe I didn't count
myself
13 I didn't look at my own hand so it's
13 all right 13 to 11 thank you very
much for helping me with
numbers that's what we're here for all
right so the motion before us ought to
pass with Amendment 11 for House Bill
1178 as amended by Amendment 1326 H the
motion by representative Maguire
seconded by representative Sweeney clerk
will call the role on that motion of o
pass as amended what you I was ask a
question all right further
discussion does this amendment of impact
the financial note at
all I think the answer is is no because
it's really about the finance so there
was a little bit of vague stuff about
because um um uh municipalities might
have Labor agreements therefore they
might be slightly affected you know that
kind of thing but but um because they
might somebody might lay off somebody
right so so
um but essentially no I mean essentially
this is more about what's going out in
in IND in Commerce than it than it is in
um but but but it definitely takes any
government because it's strictly about
going out of business right that it
takes any kind of government thing out
of the
thank
you U Mr Hoffman is there any fiscal
note on
this uh there's no fiscal note on the
amendment yet however what
representative McGuire is true um first
of all the state isn't um subject to the
provisions of this bill so it won't
impact the state uh the other Bill did
impact the university system but again
because now this is going out of
business I don't think they'll have an
impact so um there shouldn't be an
impact on this bill so if so there is no
money in the bill so we could go to if
we well it wouldn't have a vote we'd
have to have a better vote to go to
consent calendar anything all right
disregard thank you all right if there's
no further discussion clerk will call
the rooll on the motion of ought to pass
on House Bill 1178 as amended by
Amendment 1326 H motion by Maguire
seconded by
Sweeney call the RO thank you Mr
chairman
representative
Earth
no representative Maguire
yes representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative vean yes representative
hle
yes representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrell no I'm sorry I
didn't hear that no okay
sure representative Popa vich Muller
yes representa walner
no representative lean
no represent buo
no represent you uh call myself
representative Heath no no that's a no
gotcha thank you you representative
Murray oh sorry no good job
representative eel
no Representative torki
no representative haen Phillips
no representative Stringham no
representative grassy no representative
Priest
No and representative Wilder
yes Mr chair the uh m yeah this vote is
11-13 and the motion is defeated motion
is defeated is there another motion
representer grass is recognized Mr
chairman Mr chairman I'd like to uh
place
in in for consideration Amendment 1047 H
which you're getting copies made right
now I only made a couple of copies I
didn't expect it to get this far but
thank you uh for put this takes care of
this amendment that I have which you'll
be receiving shortly here um takes care
of the the University Systems
concern um it uh keeps it uh for more
than um for 15 employees and uh which
which I stated that argument
previously and it uh also limits it caps
the number of days that can be carried
uh for um unused pay uh acred on use pay
to 30 days so for most workers this will
provide them with the protection they
need to be able to make sure that they
get paid and for the hours that they've
recruited that they've worked years for
and I appreciate your support for this I
hope that we can get this passed and get
this to the floor um whether an not to
pass motion for something for the
average working people you have a fiscal
no uh it takes care of the University
Systems issue so from what I understand
it doesn't impact the state at all so
the university system said that the
amendment has a section in here which
which addresses their their concerns
so this this has no no money in
it for the state correct okay thank
you and the the correct number is 1256
age Mr CH motion the uh you said 1047
the one we got was 1256 is that check
with you represent I'm sorry I did have
the wrong number because I was holding
the wrong piece of Pap is 1256 H okay
56h further discussion on the proposed
amendment I have a
question representa H thank you Mr chair
um so you are capping this at the 30
days right in line seven and eight would
you be amendable to a smaller cap than
that most people don't acrew five weeks
of vacation or six weeks of vacation a
year that we're talking about um it's
more in the 2 to four range in terms of
weeks of vacation um because most
employers count some of the holidays
toward their vacation time when they
start acre at six weeks so um this would
allow people to acrew more than a year's
vacation the way it's drafted right
now I'm I'm not sure I understand the
question exactly but no I think 30 days
is anade one because if you work for a
company for more than 10 years there's a
chance that you could get that type of
vacation and um I've had experiences
twice where I got to the five weeks of
vacation um and U my employment ended so
you know that's uh we we figure this
will cover most people who work and uh
they may have held over days from a
previous year for V for a vacation uh
whatever and this would would provide
that protection for them most companies
they cap companies in their personnel
policies for most laborers do cap it
that you can't carry more than 30 days
at any one time of recruit
time I have a technical represent
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair I just
have a technical question because I'm
I'm still learning uh this amendment is
uh signed is um sponsored by grassy and
Cahill and Cahill is on the labor
department and and so or labor committee
and I'm just curious how this rule Works
where it the bills need or the
Amendments need to be sponsored by a
Committee Member is is having Kill from
a different committee acceptable on this
amendment because we have a finance guy
on
it you want to say
that
um we learned this morning from the
clerk that that's not true um apparently
amendments can have any state reps name
on them and if there's any other D you
didn't show up so you can't back me
[Music]
up you were there weren't
you you confirm I okay very good all
right so it's acceptable to have
representative kahill on there but is
there anybody on on the committee that
would like to Second for purposes of
today's chairman all right so it's it's
uh hang on it's um grassy and able on
this amendment that will be before for
us question over here
just oh thank you we've got a second so
all
right um where does it show that the UNH
is out of
this there was one it doesn't
specifically do it but it was one of the
issues that they had um dealing um with
the types of employ water to and
employees described in Isa
27543 uh this is something that they had
a concern with and that's what was put
in I'd have to compare it exactly
between the from the original bill and I
could tell you exactly where that was
but they did um recommend that change
and we put it in the in the bill so so
when we Define an employer as RSA 27535
it does not include the UNH yeah they
actually um have better benefits than
what this protects La so they've been
Exempted thank you thank you for that
explanation all right now we have before
for us the amendment
um 1256 on House Bill
1178 I have another question question
from representative Edwards uh thank you
Mr wer or representative wer um so maybe
representative grassy you can answer
this I uh this was alluded to
earlier uh that the definitions of time
off the the naming of time off is
changing and increasingly uh something
like slack time is is uh is being used
uh and the uh and in some um companies
sick leave is no longer an item it's
just buried within all the available
hours that a person can take off and so
um so that's not a bad policy but I'm
just curious if on line 8 where we talk
about not sick days that we wouldn't
count sick days if we're creating an
ambiguous situation for those employers
that don't account for sick days um uh
specifically or precisely and and
instead bundle them into um slack days
or
whatever um I I again as I said before
if you've taken a look at most of that
time the flex time uh um vacation time
periods or something you find more in
high-tech businesses it's very rare that
you find it in other businesses but when
you do find it in a dist and virtually
every study recently has proven this out
that people actually get less vacation
time than they would if they worked
under an traditional system this is
something that is for those people who
are hard workers who work at their job
year after year and it's just to protect
that time that they've reced um you know
mo a lot of companies do not give you
any vacation in your first year you may
have some sick days but you don't get
any vacation time and you have to prove
your sick time that you use and what
you're looking at here is a situation
where when they get to that first year
after that first year employment and
particularly if the company says your
vacation crws on January 1 they get to
that point on January 1st and they get
their acred time um if a company is
using using Flex time the way they pay
it out the way they use it is is in
their personnel policy but I will tell
you Studies have shown as I've said
people do not get as many vacation days
under Flex time than they do under
regular time and it's proving out that
people are just working more hours and
it's burning people out and the tech
industry is one that proves that you
burn people out in that business but
this is more for people who work
traditional jobs and earn that time by
working hard and and and you know it was
said that well if you want to get that
employee to come back you're going to
pay this kind of stuff out to him well
that's not the case I know a situation
where probably 90% of the people came
back to work and they all lost that
vacation time I thank you for that I I
wasn't debating the the benefit or value
of it I was asking about the technical
application given the definitions and
the use of specific words and so I I I
don't know that we know uh but we can
vote on this anyways well it obviously
exempts sick time correct so that's
that's the question you asked and I
guess that's the answer but no sick time
representative Papa M Mr chair I just
wanted to add a bit more information
here um I've heard the assertion that
this is more a thing for High-Tech
Industries and highly paid people since
I've been working for the town of wiam I
would like to briefly quote from their
personnel policy that's available on
their website Article 13 earn time earn
time is an alternative approach to the
traditional manner of covering absence
for vacation personal day leave days and
seek leave instead of dividing benefit
into a specific number of days for each
benefit earn time puts these days
together into a single benefit I'm not
going to quote the rest of the policy
because it's about six pages long
but I want to assure you that the town
of wiam is a very low Tech
employer okay and this is a significant
concern because when we start
legislating what was happening 5 years
ago and we do not recognize these
changes we can create I have no idea how
the time of town of wiam were they
covered by this would be able to apply
this because they specifically say we do
not split this so how do I know which
portion of this ear time is covered by
this law by this proposed amendment
which is not so I just wanted to bring
this to your attention I I don't have a
solution but I'm aware of this issue
thank you we might have to look up what
RSA 275
35-a defines as an employer and it since
it exempts Una it it might even exempt
Municipal County I but does anyone know
that's looked at
that represent Grassi do you know what
all the language is on I'm assuming that
the Municipal Employees are covered
under the state same statute that state
employees would be covered in they'd be
exempt I mean maybe our staff can assist
us in that I don't think they fall under
that same exemption however when they
did receive um a request for the
original fiscal note that would be too
far off from this fiscal note they said
there would be no impact to them based
on how their own Personnel rules are
written no impact on municipalities and
so on thank you for looking that up
appreciate it because obviously that was
a question in representative papovich
mller's mind so all right we have a
Amendment before
us and I guess we've changed it now to
its a motion by representative grassy
seconded by representative Abel to adopt
Amendment 1256 H is a show of hands
sufficient all right all in favor all in
favor raise your
hands two three six seven eight nine 10
11 12 13 14 I see 14 all
opposed two three four six S8 n 10
11 I didn't count myself but it's it
passed what was the count 14 to
11 minute can't be ah 10 10 14 to 10
thank
you move vote ought to pass as amended
no thought I did so it's
13 was it 13 to 11 either
way yes I wrote down 13 to 11 how did I
know that
I don't know all right any further
discussion the motion before us is ought
to pass as amended on House Bill
1178 amendment
is
1256 the motion is by representative
grassy seconded by representative
Abel further discussion seeing none the
clerk will call a role on ought to
pass as amended by
1256 thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth
no representative McGuire no
representative Petri votes
no representative of Emer
no representative of Griffin
no representative Mooney
no representative Edwards no
representative Bean no representative of
hle
no representative Sweeny
no Arizona camell no Arizona papovich
meller
no Arizona walner yes representative
Lehman
yes representative buo
yes representative uh Heath
yes representative Murray
yes representative eel yes represented
torski yes represent haken Phillips yes
represent Str
yes represent grassy yes represent
priest
yes represent wer
no Mr chair the vote is
11-13 and the motion fails all right
motion fails 11-13 is there another
motion represent a hle I move interim
study all right motion is now be for us
interim
study further
discussion who's the second on the
interim
study is there a second from any
Committee Member represent Stringham is
the
second and
Stringham Po and Stringham for interance
study further discussion on the motion
of interim
study seeing none the clerk will call a
rooll on the motion of interim study for
House Bill
I you fool me you got enough iets I do I
do I just got to get
to
representative Earth yes sorry about
that Maguire representative McGuire
yes representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes represent Sweeny yes represent
camell yes represent Popovich Muller yes
Representative walner
no representative Lehman no
representative Buco no representative um
Heath
no representative Murray
no represent evil
no represent torki
no represent hick and Phillips
no represented Stringham no represent
grassy no represent Priest No represent
wer yes Mr chair the vote is 13 to 11 in
favor of the motion of interim study all
right interim study 13-
11 moving on to there'll be there'll be
a Minority Report on that Mr chairman
Minority Report who will Who will be
writing it represent
grassy thank
you and the
minor majority report is represent hole
again
okay um one
second representative grassy will it be
otpa with your yes okay thank
you all right house bill 1649 representa
lean thank you Mr chairman so House Bill
1649 relative to prohibiting certain
products with intentionally added PF I'd
like to recognize representative eel
will speak to the bill and she has an
amendment I believe thank you very much
um chair leean um I move ought to pass
on um HB
1649 and I do have an amendment to offer
and is your Amendment
1086 it is thank you
second who was the second Murray thank
you Mooney
Mooney well hasn't been
here oh
yes the amendment that I'm uh referring
to once again is
10868 H um it's somewhat difficult to
talk about the amendment I guess if I
don't talk about the bill itself uh
first but um this bill is a bill that
would uh ban the sale of products that
have pasas intentionally added to them
and the ban is to take effect in the
bill in July of
2028 but through the the com through the
process in Commerce we did um refine the
bill we removed certain uh Provisions
that would make it more challenging for
uh manufacturers to comply with and so
it was felt in the division that moving
the ban uh effective date up to January
1st
2027 was a good idea and the amendment
uh was adopted either 8 to one or
7-2 within the um within the
division thank
you any further discussion on the
amendment yes representative Maguire
thank you so I'm going to vote against
this because I'm against the bill as a
whole which I'll talk about when we get
to it um but this is moving the
effective date up 18 months essentially
and so I'm against doing it at all ra
and even more also against doing it
sooner so further
discussion representative
Earth can I ask a question sure the
amendment ends with a colon relating to
the
products
that a list basically is expected there
yes so where's the list I mean this is
the difficulty of talking about the
amendment before we actually talk about
the bill so so in the uh bill I have the
bill yes in the in the bill as uh it was
um as it was passed by the house if you
look on page four line 36 you'll see the
uh you'll see the product list thank you
very
much uh personally I have stated that I
was in strong support of the meramac uh
ex testing and I think that
that will be the first instance of human
testing to try to discover the effect of
pasas what I think the uh Department of
Environmental security has set is
unreasonable they can't show me any real
backup uh data other than rodents that
12 parts per trillion is such a
ridiculously low thing that 10 years ago
we couldn't have measured that small in
amount and the
meramac uh testing going forward will
finally give us some human testing and I
hope that a lot of people get tested and
I think probably any one of us has more
than 12 parts per trillion in our body
and I wish that they would come out and
do testing and I would be happy to
volunteer to be tested for p and see how
much effect it has had on me and I'm in
good health so I'm opposed to Banning
things before we have real data from
humans this is going to be a very
expensive especially especially if if we
get away with Dees going to 12 parts per
trillion on every water system in the
state without real data so I I can see
why there's a push to do this because of
what's happened in marac but to my mind
it's incomplete at this point Thank you
anybody
else representative Griffin I I've I've
kind of come full circle I was impressed
with how much work U uh representative
EV had had done on this bill and I know
she spent hours and hours and and
consulted with a lot of people but I'm
still afraid you know there's there's
some other states that have
bills and we this bill is you know it's
it's setting the trail kind of Blazing
the trail we're ahead of the federal
government which usually is not the case
and I think I've come full circle on it
so I I'm I don't think I'm going to
support it I was I was more in support
and committee originally but the more I
the more I thought about it and looked
at the situation I'm just afraid that
we're doing it without with insufficient
knowledge to know what we're
doing representative eel thank you um m
Mr chair I was going to wait to talk
about the more substantive um parts of
the bill until we had voted on the
amendment but I feel like we're talking
about the substantive Parts at this
point so I'd like to have an opportunity
to talk about the bill itself um first
of all I just would like to say that St
gobain was the first instance in which
the people in maram and many of the area
towns experienced p and PAs contamin
ation we all know about the uh terrible
effects of that and the state is already
um spending upwards of hundred million
in remediation costs um and the state
actually is in the middle of a huge um
uh lawsuit to recoup the damages for
that and in the complaint itself it
lists all the problems with past that
we've come to to know about so St gobain
uh was number one we now have a ticking
time bomb in the fact that many many of
our products I mean practically
everything you look at has p in it um
this bill was well discussed and
reviewed in Commerce we had a very full
hearing on it and we had two lengthy
work sessions and we discussed in great
detail the policy itself the products
certain exclusions which I worked out um
and and many other aspects of the bill
uh Commerce did vote 16-3 in favor of
ought to pass as amended and they were
enthusiastic about uh the prospect of
this bill there was no debate on the
floor whatsoever and the bill passed on
a Voice vote um I Heard very few stray
voices I won't say it was unanimous but
there was virtually no disagreement on
the bill um in the division it was
recommended for a passage 5 to four um I
brought the bill as the chair of the
state's Solid Waste working group which
is a broad stakeholder group that
includes industry people um Advocates
municipalities it's a very broad group
and it was brought forward in support of
the state's Solid Waste Management plan
uh in an effort to reduce toxicity in
the waist stream the toxicity uh comes
from the products the products that goes
into US it goes into landfills landfill
leachate it's in Wastewater wastewater
treatment plants drinking utilities um
and and or drinking water ground water
and so when I put forth the bill it was
astonishing the broad support that the
bill had and I think only something like
P could bring together landfill
operators clean water Advocates
wastewater treatment plant operators
drinking utilities um the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and the Public
Health Association as well as um
epidemiologists um this bill I have
carefully crafted and discussed with the
Commerce Committee the items that are
included for Banning are being are also
being banned in other states quite a few
of them um and the deadline of 2027
actually is two years after 2025 when
all of the um other bands are going into
effect the items proposed are carpets or
rugs um which bear huge P load into our
landfills and it's also where our
children crawl around Cosmetics directly
apply to our faces there's a lot of
exposure there textile treatments is
fabric treatments the things that you
put on your carpets and I'm sorry if
this is banned your spaghetti stain
might not come off as easily feminine
hygiene products um food packaging which
obviously uh to the extent that it has P
fast we're ingesting it juvenile
products and I'd like to really put in a
plug for this these are products that
are sold for children that are 12 years
years old and under I don't know about
you but I don't necessarily want my
grandchild sleeping on a mattress with
peass or wearing diapers with them and
um it's a real concern personal
protective equipment our professional
firefighters were staunch um supporters
of this bill upholstered furniture again
I've mentioned the spaghetti problem and
then textile Furnishings are um things
like your your drapes so you're inside
and you're breathing the uh the pasas
that's how that um list was developed it
was taking into consideration direct
exposure and also past load in our in
our landfills um I want to just quickly
bring to your attention um a Minnesota
study which said that um pasas can be
bought for 50 to ,000 per pound but cost
between two .7 and $18 million per pound
to remove and Destroy from Municipal
Wastewater now I'd just like to mention
we've all we're all very familiar in
this uh committee the amount of money
that has been spent on upgrading
wastewater treatment plants I can tell
you that there are federal regulations
being considered where uh testing will
have to be done for Waste Water being
released into surface water and
groundwater for pasas that does not
happen now and I shudder to think the
amount of money it's going to cost for
Wastewater um treatment upgrades we
already know that our drinking water
utilities are uh staggering under the
cost of doing that so whether you agree
that the testing limits are too low or
not those costs um exist as far as
finances um you know this has one um
employee at Dees to uh oversee the
program and get it going it is time
capped at the so it doesn't keep going
so we can reassess if we need that
position to keep going at the request of
uh the chair of Commerce that is in
there um and then there's an
appropriation of
$250,000 to get the um get the program
going will'll be participating in
multi-state Clearing Houses which
streamline the process for
manufacturers
so
um when you go through all those things
um and you think about the unbelievable
burden that the state of New Hampshire
is already struggling with and our
people are facing Health Care concerns
and extreme costs it makes every bit of
sense not to keep using pasas in our
products but to stop the problem at the
source and this is our opportunity
and I think our state should be really
proud to step forward considering what
it's already been through from the from
the uh from these chemicals so with that
Mr chair I'm not sure when you would
like to vote on the amendment but I
thought considering that everything else
was being discussed I should um talk
about the bill substantively so thank
you thank you thank you for all your
research did you're welcome did the
firefighting foam get removed um so so I
I I'm happy to talk about it this all
day as anybody knows but um actually in
the order of bands firefighting foam was
um the p and firefighting foam was
banned by New Hampshire in 2020 and if
you look at my graph we were actually
the first state to do that um and the
definition that is in this bill is the
same definition and um the firefighters
are really excited that we're going to
go forward uh well with any luck here uh
we're going to go forward to ban
additional uh products and I just want
to reemphasize that this is a business
Public Health clean water advocacy uh
supported Bill bringing together groups
that you might not see again any time
soon thank you for your thoroughness
sure all right we have before us is
there any further discussion on the
amendment that's the first item we have
before us seeing none all right the
amendment before us is
1086 anybody object to show of hands all
in favor of the amendment 1086 please
raise your
hands 13 any
opposed
all right I didn't vote 13-7 the the
amendment is
adopted we got 24 people the hell did
you count who else didn't vote 13 to 11
13 to
okay all right so now the motion before
us is ought to pass on House Bill 1649
as amended by uh Amendment
1086 is there any further discussion on
that motion of aop pass as amended
representative Mooney thank you Mr
chairman Mr
chairman I along with seven other
representatives in this house represent
the town of
miramac in
2016 miramac became the ground floor of
the biggest environment mental disaster
in the state's history agree St gobain
performance Plastics which is closing
very soon spread P to our air our soil
our
water to this day I have constituents on
bottled water say that again bottled
water that's for bathing cooking
and
drinking I want to remind this committee
that as part of the budget last year we
included a phase three of a feasibility
report for health at a cost of about
$500,000 now phase three has only been
uh granted or
needed two times in 10 years why because
of the severity of concentrated cancer
cases in my
town we have spent hundreds of millions
of dollars already on this scenario but
I want to talk about the hundreds of
thousands of hours we have spent as a
community on commissions with the
Department of Environmental Services
with the Department of Health and Human
Services litigation negotiation town
Council private you know behind closed
doors and really the conclusion is all
the same the only way to stop it is to
prohibit it and this bill starts that
prohibition so for that reason I will be
voting yes on this bill and I encourage
all to do the same thank you Mr chair
thank you further discussion
representative Maguire thank you Mr
chairman um I have a a handout um that
kind of I want to illustrate what what
it is we're doing with this um uh with
this bill so the bill does not just
ban um the definition of pasas in the
bill is not just the chemical um that
was in
marac it's
15,000 chemical combinations right that
are that are all quite
useful to Industry right so and we're
not talk and and the number of products
involved in the ban
um must be in the hundreds of thousands
that are
affected um so this is the this is the
um uh front page of uh Wikipedia on PT
Fe which is uh the technical term for
teflon so what the bill defines as p is
fully fluorinated carbon so if you look
at the chemical formula here for for
PTFE it's a carbon atom with two Florine
atoms attached to it and it's in this
long string it's attached to other
carbon atoms so what the bill bands is
any chem any item that has a chemical
formula with one of these such carbon
atoms right so if somewhere in the in
the chemical formula of the item there
is a carbon atom and two Florine atoms
attached to it this bill and it's on the
list of of items being banned this bill
bans it that's what we Define as pasas
here so it's not just whatever was in
marac right which was
something I I believe was a precursor to
PTFE but but it's like anything and that
incl the that particular
definition um if you go to the back page
this is just a section of things that
include such such chemicals right so
lubricants kitchen wear so Teflon itself
is not banned by this bill as far as I
can tell
um even though it ATT it it touches food
and all that sort of stuff um the soles
the plates on irons not banned by this
bill but things that are um fabric
related things so the
bill um bans any
textile that has PTF p p in it by that
definition so that that as far as I know
is
gortex um and it also bans any kind of
um stain resistance stuff stain
resistant carpet um Scotch Guard all
that kind of stuff right um but but you
see how you see all these uses medical
uses this is often used on catheters for
example um uh Sports and medical stuff
uh pyrotechnics etc etc so so this is
anything that has
15,000 useful
compounds this is a big deal this is not
you know some some little something that
that we can just say take that thing off
the market right this is this is in all
kinds of things and it's very
useful because it's so stable right they
they call this the forever chemical but
it's it's so stable because it won't
combine with other things that's what
makes it stain resistant right it it
keeps the thing that wants to combine
with your carpet off your carpet or the
or the or the water off your jacket or
the whatever right the one word in the
bill that it banss is
ink right so so in in the grocery store
every container has a label if the ink
on that label has pest in it by this
definition has one of those atoms in the
in the chemical that makes up the ink
that item that canabas or whatever it is
will be
banned right so um well that label on
that can right you'd have to come up
with a label that doesn't but but it
seems to me that it's likely that that
the property of pasas is important to
the printing process right that that the
the it has the property that it doesn't
combine with water right so that's the
way a lot of printing works is is you
put water down on a printing plate then
you dip it in ink and the ink sticks to
the places that don't have the water and
then you print right
so so I'm not sure we know everything
that's being banned here right and and
the idea that this could this ban of
hundreds of every every label on the in
every in every shelf of the grocery
store uh every piece of cloth on you
know sold in any store that that somehow
we're going to regulate all that with
one
employee I I mean this is a feel-good
kind of thing it's it can't it it
necessarily has to be selective
enforcement um and so therefore they can
decide well I'll go after you today or
I'll get go after you today I mean if if
they went to some Craft brewery and said
I suspect that that uh the ink on your
beer can contains P the way the bill is
written the person who who sells the
beer who who makes the beer can would
have to send a letter back with with a
cert you know with a a big shot
signature on it saying no it doesn't
right otherwise the beer is banned well
who's going to sign such a letter do you
think the the the Craft brewery knows
what's in the ink on the their cans you
know I mean it's just
um this is a a big deal and and the
amount of money involved is not the
$240,000 in the fiscal note it's it's
going to be big big stuff all throughout
industry and and the state in my opinion
um all right so I'm I'm going to put
more in my floor speech and so on but I
but I you know I'm I'm definitely
opposed to this thank you thank you Mr
chair represent Abel and then
representative papichi then
representative
Murray I mean we could talk about this
for a really long time there's I would
argue that because we have a chemical
that is a forever chemical that's used
in so many products that is found
throughout our state in our soil because
the USG has done studies in our
groundwater because Dees has a dashboard
that shows it is precisely the reason
why we have to stop somewhere to stop
the proliferation of this chemical um
you
know with due respect to representative
Maguire um I have literally spent five
to six months on this researching the
chemistry researching the products um I
didn't bring forth a bill that I thought
would be over the toop for the State of
New Hampshire I brought forth a bill
that has products that are banned in it
that are being banned in quite a few
other states larger States than New
Hampshire so the manufacturers are
already in the process and this is like
a case of dominoes you can keep pushing
things along and you know uh Cosmetics
for instance in California they have a
100% ban on P and cosmetics this is
intentionally added um the whole thing
you can talk about 15,000 chemicals you
can talk about all the products the fact
of the matter is that when you have
these Florine chlorine bonds that's what
makes them the forever chemical and
that's what makes them um in many cases
toxic and that's why they're everywhere
and you know I have sat with the
toxicologist for the State of New
Hampshire we've gone over chemical
equations until he was blue in the face
and I'm not sure what color I was but we
need to start somewhere and I guess the
one other thing I want to say is that I
also chose products where the p in the
product was not something that was
essential to the product there are no
medical devices in here they're excluded
there's no drugs that are in here that
are excluded um you
know so and when and then the other uh
analysis I did was for our children and
also the amount of pfast load that goes
into the landfills and into our
Wastewater stream so you know it is I'll
say it is a big deal it's really really
important and we have to stop using this
stuff in our products for the future of
our
state representative papovich Mller
then representative Heath then
representative grass thank you Mr
chairman I deeply appreciate the real
issue that sorry yeah okay I really
appreciate the fact that we absolutely
have a situation in marac and across the
state that needs addressing I appreciate
the passion and the work invested in
this by everybody who is involved in
preparing the bill I still am unable to
support it and I'll be as brief I can as
I can be poison is a matter of those
anytime we talk poison and we do not
talk those we are not being scientific
we are not being reasonable we are not
being fact
based I'm drinking
soda caffeine is poisonous in the right
dosage taking off of it you die even
more fun water is poisonous in the wrong
dosage you drink enough of it you die so
without talking those everything is
poisonous almost
everything marijuana is somehow an
exception you'd have to eat about 20
times your body weight to suffer from
it so without talking about dosage
anything that bans stuff and does not
specify a dose is not going to be
scientifically based anything that does
not address the fact that the huge
problems that we are suffering are due
to due to past practices that are not
going to be repeated I mean stuff like s
gobain stuff like what happened in wiam
where the town unknowingly dumped you
know firefighting foam into the ground
because they did not realize it was
toxic all that stopped happening I I
have not seen one shred of evidence to
show me that all these things that we
are looking to ban here are in any way
contributing to our problem as far as I
can tell our problem has been that
industrial amounts of this stuff have
been dumped into the water supply
because we did not know better and we
stopped doing that and if somebody
knowing today what they know still does
it my God hit them as hard as you can
but this seems to be amazingly broad I
you know I heard California mentioned
that in reference to the fact that our
laws are not as strict as Cali I'll end
my argument by pointing out that
California has a consumer notification
law that requires that an warning lab is
placed on any product that has contains
a product a compound known to the state
of California to cause cancer do you
know what that label is on
everything everything and as a result
nobody pays attention to it because with
everything is cancer inducing clearly
nothing is I believe we need to address
this I think that we need to remediate
there are a lot of things that we can do
to me this is a bit too broad and please
understand that I say that with the most
utmost respect for everybody involved
and I understand the reasons why people
want to promote this legislation but I
did want to be on the record as do I
cannot support it thank you
representative Murray then
representative
grass thank you Mr chair um just as an
aside I think the people in marac who
are dealing with cancer would probably
have a different perspective than what I
just heard um but I have I'm hearing two
different um perhaps definitions and I'm
hoping um representative Abel can sort
that out um she had said that she's
using the definition that firefighters
used for the pasas and then we have this
handout is this the same thing as what
the firefighters used or are they they
is this a thank
you um thank you very much for the
question um the definition that is in
this bill is Broad so that it would
include all sorts of
permutations of um of the chemical like
if you switch out an oxygen or you
switch out a hydrogen or something like
that it's it's broad so that it includes
uh chemicals with um that Florine Bond
so that also by having a broader
definition it anticipates the
development of additional complex
chemicals down the
line representative grassy
yes Mr chairman thank
you I think as representative eel said
we have to start somewhere agriculture
in Maine is being destroyed because of
biosolids Municipal biosolids have been
spread on fields and they're finding PE
fast in their in their vegetables and
their plants that are and in their their
grasses that are feeding their cows um
and and this is impacted because of
sludge that they get from water
treatment plants municipal water
treatment plants the stuff we use every
day that's going down your drain waste
management is spending millions of
dollars to pre-treat their their leech
eight because they're finding past in
their leech eight because of products
that represented Bill wants to ban are
being disposed of in their in their
landfill we have to start somewhere to
reduce that so maybe at some point in
time we can end that going into the
leech eight so waste management is
doesn't have to continue to spend
Millions year after year to to fight
this and it doesn't go into our waste
water and into our water treatment
plants and and and and then into the
sludge that we have which is which is
which when purified is uses biosolids on
farmlands we have to work with our
agricultural people the you want to have
incidence of where where cancer has been
found I mean you're not just looking at
St gobain but look at the Cancer
clusters in the Sea Coast Area because a
firefighting foam that was used at peas
they're finding out that this is has
been a problem in fact everywhere I
remember when P said hey we're going to
give you a good thing all your
communities you're going to get
firefighting foam and we actually
sprayed it on Main Street and kids were
dancing in the stuff but you know it's
something we Now find and they're
finding that places where fire
departments use this foam in some of
their practices they're finding is the
groundwater is contaminated because of
that take a look at the one of the
largest lawsuits in the country right
now is Camp leun because of firefighting
foram and past now we banned
firefighting foam but we have to start
somewhere with the materials that we're
putting out our landfills that are going
into down our drains and this is the
first step to do that New Hampshire has
to be proactive in this case what we're
looking at is cumul effects cumulative
impacts that have occurred over the
years and the only way we're going to
stop it is to reduce the amount of
materials with past that we dispose of
and this is the first place we
start further discussion all right
representative Edwards and
representative PRI uh thank you Mr chair
I I haven't uh been following along with
the details of this bill and have just
read it and the the parts of what I've
heard here today by fellow committee
members that really resonate with me is
that we have to start somewhere okay so
what so what how do I translate that I I
I translate that to mean let's let's
start with a small step that takes care
of the things that we really know to be
a problem uh we we you know the
manufacturing and uh meramac we we we
should certainly ban that the foam we've
already banned but this list doesn't
look like starting somewhere uh in the
actual bill the number of products
affected are extremely long and I uh I I
can't vote for such a large list of
items all at once because I don't think
we can anticipate sort of the economic
and consumer impact of pulling all those
items out of the um sale channels um and
uh and and what kind of unknown
consequences we might have from uh
government induced scarcity for example
so so if If This Were A narrower Bill
where we solved what we knew we needed
to solve and set up a process to to to
let manufacturers know that uh they have
to come to us to demonstrate the
efficacy of their product and we could
use the same list but but put the B us
on them to come to us and explain the
safety issues before some date you know
5 7 years from now so that we
don't um accidentally um kill a Golden
Goose here I mean let's let's solve the
problem but let's not over engineer the
solution and this feels like over
engineer over engineering to me so at
this point I I don't think I could
support uh anything but an inter interim
study representative PRI thank you Mr
chairman I will be supporting this bill
um
120% because I see it as a the first
step in trying to address paaps in New
Hampshire um right now it's currently
banned in Canada and in
Europe and in several of our states um
so this is not a new thing and I believe
that the bill that's been worked out by
representative eel is well researched
well thought out and the list of
products is very conservative when you
consider the whole spectrum that could
have been on this list and lastly I you
know after being a a cancer
survivor and knowing that the cancer
rates have spiked up in marac and the
communities around it
because of the contamination I think
it's time for us who are supposed to be
looking out for the welfare and safety
of our people to do something about this
thank
you further discussion representative
Maguire uh thank you Mr chairman I I I
want to address two things here uh first
of all cancer
um people may be under the impression
that in general Cancer's On The Rise but
that's not so and in particularly in New
Hampshire it's not so so if you go to
the cdc's website they have um charts of
cancer mortality over the years and and
in general for the country the rates the
number of can cancer deaths per
100,000 have been declining over the
last uh 20 plus years um but in
particular for New Hampshire they have
been declining even faster so New
Hampshire was in
2005 in the second worst quintile of
cancer rates for the country in
2014 I think it is we were in the middle
quintile of cancer rates for the country
and in
2021 we are in the second best quintile
of of canc rates for the country so even
though the country's overall cancer
rates are declining New Hampshire's are
declining even faster so that says that
to the extent that this is I mean these
are all cancers so you know lung cancer
and other things too um but but to the
extent that this is a cancer problem
it's
not as significant as as overall Cancers
and other Cancers and so on okay second
thing I want to talk about is is the
broadness of the definition so um you'll
notice that the list doesn't include
things that people actually swallow
right it's only consumer goods that sort
of thing you know labels on cans and
things like that but the food in the can
is not on this list or the medications
and so on so the theory here is that if
I throw away the can with the ink that
has p
in it that's going to go into my um uh
solid waste facility there'll be
leachate that'll go down into the
groundwater at some point I'm going to
drink the groundwater and so on well all
those steps dilute what's in the what's
on the label right they don't they don't
concentrate what's on the label and um
and in
particular there are chemicals that meet
the this definition having a fully
fluorinated uh carbon atom that people
take every day including the number one
prescription drug in America it's
something called lipore uh people take
it to reduce their cholesterol the
chemical formula for lipor Al generic is
called atorvastatin I think um has this
atom in it so had the word medication be
on the band list
that would ban the number one
prescription drug in America um proac
has it as well and hundreds of other
medications so the idea that anything
with this atom in it is
harmful all these medications that have
this as part of their formula have been
thoroughly tested for safety right if if
lipor caused
cancer um it wouldn't have been approved
right they go through extensive
extensive training so the the definition
is way too broad we don't know I mean
certainly there's there's useful
chemicals that have that that would meet
that definition that aren't being banned
by this bill but you know anyways so
again I'm against it thank
you is this going to go on all
day I hope not
represent Hull then represent hacken
Phillips thank you Mr chair um having
spent time in the industry when I was in
college relative to fluorinated
substances that ended up in the printing
ink to to Mr McGuire's Point earlier
it's all over um it's used all the time
in magazines it that industry has used
wax and lubricants made with Teflon for
a number of years I do think we should
talk about the cookware side of this
it's not in the bill and those I would
ask everybody on the on this committee
to think about the last time you use
non-stick cookware because that is the
biggest contributor to what's in your
body it's not necessarily what's in in
the leate that's going into the ground
that's going right that's going into the
water supply um let's look for the
biggest sources before we start banning
all of
these represent hacken Phillips thank
you Mr chair I just wanted to refocus
the discussion for a moment U we've
heard a lot of about the substantive
policy this afternoon and I um just
wanted to remind the committee that it
is our duty to be reviewing the fiscal
uh impact of this bill um I as I
understand it we're reviewing a
250,000 annual
appropriation um and I believe the
reasoning to support that um is that you
know a penny today will save us a dollar
in the future I do believe that this
bill is wise for our state's economic
future and I hope that you will join the
bipartisan co-sponsors as well as bamal
co-sponsors of this bill to help uh
protect our state moving forward based
on that economic decision thank
you any further
discussion representative eel I hope
just quickly on the fiscal note this is
a fiscal note uh thing it's a one-time
expenditure of
$250,000 to try to to uh get the program
um to get the program up and going and
one employee and I just I have to say
that there's this is a weird way to say
it there's more to life than cancer
there we've had a lot of discussion here
about cancer the the things that pasas
can also cause is pregnancy induced
hypertension preclampsia liver damage
increased cholesterol so take more lipor
no um increased increased risk of
thyroid disease uh all sorts of IM
immunity
interrupts they're finding pasas in
breast milk they're finding pasas in
newborn
infants um it really is everywhere but
just because it's everywhere that's all
the more reason to stop Banning as much
as we can from the from the front end
and um yes I made certain choices on the
products that I've included here but
I've explained to you why I did and you
know there are other states that
considered across the board bands I did
not do that so um and we've also removed
some some things that were in it uh
through the process and commerce so um I
can't stress more how important it is to
stop the use of p as its source send a
message to
manufacturers that even though our
spaghetti May stain a little bit more we
don't want any more of this stuff in the
products we use and that our children
are subjected to thank you is there any
further discussion seeing none are you
ready for the
question we have adopted Amendment 1086
for House Bill
1649 it's moved ought to pass by
representative Abel seconded by
representative Mooney there's no further
discussion the clerk will call the role
on the motion of ought to pass as
amended thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth
no representative Maguire no
representative Petri votes no
representative em
yes representative Griffin
no representative Mooney
yes representative Edwards
no representative Bean
no represent a hole
no represent of Sweeney yes
representa of camell
no representative Povich Muller
no representative walner yes
representative Lehman
yes representative buo
yes representative uh yes Heath Heath oh
you beat me to it representative Murray
yes representative eel uh
yes I had that one down before you said
it representative torski
yes represent hen Phillips yes repr
representative Stringham
yes representative grassy yes
representative priest yes representative
Wier
yes Mr chairman the vote is 15 to9 in
favor of the motion okay 15 to9 that
motion is adopted going to the regular
calendar
right we
finished Minority Report okay is Karen
writing the main report Karen repr are
you reading the
report what's what's the motion that
auto pass yeah Auto pass is amended all
right I think we're finished with
division
one and I know okay division two is
patiently been waiting 15
to9 okay right recognized representative
Emer for House Bill 21 1212
1212 yes Mr chair this relative to oh
that's that the wrong one relative to
eligibility for free School
meals I asked
representive mu for a
motion thank you I'd like to make a
motion of itl on below 1212 and uh speak
to my
motion okay you are recognized to speak
to motion is there a second on the
motion second Emme thank you thank you
um since we've really talked a lot about
it in finance too I will be brief also
recognizing the time of the day
already this bill is U advocated for in
the name of U you know helping hungry
children get fed what we have not seen
at any point is any evidence that at
least one kid in one school has been
denied food as a result of their
inability to pay for lunch what the bill
really should be about is making sure
that school districts that are
serving children who cannot pay for
lunch food and do not get paid for it at
the end of that school year we should be
looking at covering that balance for the
school districts that have given food
without the expectation that the child
you know will pay for it instead we are
looking at this bill that greatly
expands the eligibility of you know
who's eligible for a free and clear meal
but shouldn't really make a difference
in who gets food or not when I served on
the uh joint Senate house committee that
uh looked at the impact of direct
Medicaid
certification we did ask this very
question because we were also dealing
with hunger in schools and the
Department of Education indicated that
at this point in time they do not have
data that would show us how much of
those balances are left on the shoulders
of the local taxpayers to cover for at
the end of the year we did ask them to
provide that data once that data is
available I would fully support the bill
that would deal with the fact that you
know the state should help the school
districts pay for those funds that they
cannot collect but since this bill would
spend much much more and really not
have the ability to show any impact in
actually addressing child hanger child
child hunger in schools I would advocate
for an ideal motion on it I would also
point out that um you know this was a
bit of a very close call in the house
where I believe it failed first and then
it was reconsidered or you know sorry
yes so U it's not like this is a place
where the house has specifically spoken
with a broad margin on policy thank
you the parts of this bill I recall the
normal
um free and reduced meals are based at
160% of federal poverty uh levels and
for free and 185% for for uh reduced
this bill would have increased it to
350% of FPL to to bring in more people
that sounds wonderful but the ad
adustment is you're going from something
that is almost more than 50% Federal
money to one that would be all the rest
would be 100% State money and and and
the uh Department of Education I think
came in quite a list of people they
wanted to hire because this takes in a
whole group that has never been covered
before and would all be covered by state
funds rather than a big participation by
federal so I think that the reason why
it failed in division 2 because it was a
big increase in government and there was
no thought that there were really that
many hungry children it's it's just
being used a lot and sometimes it's a
choice the child runs out of the house
without taking the lunch or whatever or
spends the money that they get were
given for lunch on candy on the way so
we don't know all these things but there
was some talk of that and it it failed
in in division two further discussion
representative Emory yes uh thank you Mr
chair to add add to that approach uh
this actually was going to create a new
Department uh because it doesn't the
systems don't exist to manage State
money for this application the current
systems the electronic systems that
exist are for the federal program this
was a an advanced program run by the
state and we don't have anything in
place we don't have Staffing and we
don't have a system so we're basically
setting up a new Department with a new
application representative Heath thank
you Mr chair um this bill was authored
by our former colleague art Ellison um
and I I'm sure you all noticed your
emails um that
hb212 generated quite an amount of
emails actually the day that we failed
to pass this bill in division 2 um
representative waler and I went to visit
our and he got busy on his computer
reaching out to as many people as he
could to alert them you saw people out
here this morning who were standing up
for children and their
food excuse me I just want to say we
have a
100,000 poor people in New Hampshire we
have hundreds and hundreds of children
who come to school every single day and
for the most part the only meals they
get are the meals that they get at
school my years of working in
education we were worried so much about
kids over the summer because we knew
that they wouldn't have that regular
food program and actually we worked in
Manchester to come up with a summer
feeding program for
children what this bill does is it
raises the um poverty level to 350% and
I believe we've done that for
efas um the poverty rate yes it it's
beyond what the federal government
allows for and yes there would be some
work at the department of Ed they
wouldn't have to do a whole different
department they would have to set up
different
systems we know that children who are
who are hungry aren't learning to the
extent that they should be learning I'm
not going to go on and on the hour is
late and I know that we all want to get
going um but I would like you to think
about the importance of this bill and
what it brings to the poorest of
children in the state of New Hampshire
we're a wealthy State for the most part
but we do have poor children our young
families and I look at them in
Manchester of which we have
many more children would be eligible and
those bills that school districts get
would be reduced by the fact that more
children would be eligible for free and
reduced lunch so I hope that you will
consider voting against the itl motion
so that we can make another motion and
thank you to my colleagues further
discussion represent hackin Phillips
thank you Mr chair and just to bring up
a note about some of the fiscal impact
that we discussed in
subcommittee um on page I guess the last
page of the fiscal note the department
provides estimate totals for um arrange
between 50 and 75 million um to the
state as a result of the um possible
addition of both of breakfast and lunch
being served um to this additional
population of students um up to the 350
percentage rate of the um federal
poverty line and um it was noted in
committee that this was a very um
expansive range um it was actually what
they term to be a conservative
estimate and um the department did
provide that number but will call the
committee's attention to the fact that
not every child will take advantage of
both breakfast and lunch in some cases
the child may only take advantage of one
or none at all um so we have to realize
that this number could actually be much
lower and that um you know the
Department's job was to Pro to provide
us with the you know the most
significant number that could Encompass
the whole program um but we know that
that's that may not come to fruition um
and furthermore um to address the
additional employees that would be
needed to um administrate this program
within the Department of Education it
was three so we're talking about three
new desks three new computers and three
new employees um to to the Department's
um conservative um estimations so again
it might not be that many people um so I
just like to you know tear off the
Band-Aid I think a lot of people are
seeing big numbers and Afraid of that
fact but I want to let you know that the
policy has been decided by this um
chamber already and that we're really
talking about the administrative costs
of the state at this point um which I
would argue is not that much in order to
feed the children
thanks further discussion on the uh
motion of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill
1212 seeing none are you ready for the
question clar will call a roll
on House Bill 1212 the motion is
inexpedient to legislate offered by
representative papovich seconded by
ripsom
Emer very good thank you uh Mr
chair representative erif yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Ed
yes representative Bean yes
representative hle yes representative
Sweeny yes representative Cal yes
representative papovich Muller yes
Representative walner no representative
lean no Representative buo no
representative uh Heath Heath yes
Heath
no I already had it down representative
Murray no
Representative vble no represent torski
no represent haken Phillips no
representative Stringham no
representative grassy no representative
Priest No representative Wier yes Mr
chair the vote is 13 to1 in favor of the
motion of itl itl is
adopted moving on to
division and there will be a Minority
Report
okay that is Heath uh m m Mr chair yes I
think we're getting ready to get back
into division three and and I would ask
you to consider bringing up uh 1595
before 1573 we have a couple people
who've been waiting here all day to do
1595 all right without objection we'll
go to 1595 next
representative um Edwards is
recognized right now I think Mr Ripple
is handing out the amendment on this
it's got my name on it uh uh it's it's
actually the uh the Hutchins Amendment
I've been calling that that she's
probably heard it me say that five times
so she probably doesn't think it's cute
or funny anymore but it's it's
nevertheless true uh earlier when we
were doing um
1964 I mentioned then that
1595 was was tightly related to uh
1564 uh because it it hit it hits in the
same area if you looked at at the at the
two fiscal notes they had exactly the
same dollar amount for 105 oh I guess I
I I should stop there and and and make a
motion to uh adopt Amendment
1178 is there a second second represent
a
whole may I speak to the motion yes okay
so I I already spoke a lot about it but
uh to to continue um what um these two
bills originated independently they both
impacted the same it system they each
rolled in with their own fiscal note for
exact the same dollar amount um they
were initially in conflict with one
another you couldn't really do them both
you had to pick one or the other and
that was a dilemma and so we had a
citizen U Miss Rebecca Hutchins do some
really nice work to deconflict 64 and 95
so that they could coexist well together
uh what in part what she did was she
accept accepted the um in the amendment
the parenting time definition that was
in ' 64 to end that conflict and and and
then really the only thing that um uh
persisted from the original 95 from a
policy perspective was um a formula that
would be used in the cases where
co-parenting and uh allocation of uh
time and and or money was uh being used
uh the the recommendation for a formula
has showed up in a couple of uh uh
reports that the state uh spent
considerable time and money on um you'd
hope that they were good recommendations
but the recommendations for a formula
were in multiple reports uh this does
that um you would think I would think
not working in the
Judiciary that um have having a formula
to calculate things like co-parenting
time and and uh sharing of of resources
that having a formula would make it
really simple it'd make it transparent
everyone would know what to expect it
would reduce conflict and and enhance
understanding um the the the concern is
that in some cases such as domestic
violence the the the formula may be
inappropriate but nevertheless the judge
retains the authority and our current
law to make a a different decision based
on the best interests of the child so
this is a this this amendment brings
forth A U is a replace all for 95 it uh
um makes it compatible from a
definitions perspective it adds a simple
to understand and simple to use formula
that can be overridden in particular
circumstances by the judge anyways so I
I think I think it's a really nice
compromise it doesn't spend any more
money because we accepted
1564 this amendment essentially has no
dollar cost because the same it CH
change can be done for both of them so
it's it's one charge one time and and we
allocated that over to 1564 so this is
kind of a freebie in a
way thank you further discussion
representa tersi thank you Mr
chairman um first I just I believe
either I
misheard representative Edwards or he
misspoke he said this was a
complete rewrite or replace all of the
bill and I think that was incorrect this
is not a replace all um so I want to
clarify that second on our sheet here um
that lists how it came out of division
it's listed as the vote as 72 in fact we
reconsidered and the final vote on this
was 6-3 it's not reflected on our sheet
I want to make sure that we're aware of
that
um I think I have more to say on the
bill uh once the amendment is dealt with
however um I'll just say that I don't
think the amendment actually um
addressed some of the concerns that the
committee had
um but I appre appreciate the effort to
try and make
um both bills compatible um I just don't
believe that it was successful in doing
that so I will leave it at that so
you're absolutely right in both your
Corrections thank you for that and and I
failed to mention that this uh policy
passed the house in the larger version 7
to6 or U uh it it passed their committee
7 to6 and passed the house already so we
we've got an approved policy that no
longer costs any
money thank you all right further
discussion all right uh we have an
amendment before us
1178 without objection those in favor
show by raising your
hands 13 those
opposed
11 I don't see 11 one two three four I
think you only got 12 the first time was
it was I wrong on the first count I
think so all
right 1311 1311 the motion pass the
motion's
adopted Mr chair I believe it was 1410
with rep Heath on a yes all right 14 to
10 either way it passes all right motion
now before us is House Bill 1595 ought
to pass as
amended with house with Amendment
1178 the motion is by representative
Edward seconded by representative Hull
is there any further discussion on the
on the bill as amended representative
tersi thank you I appreciate the time um
for those of you on division 3 know that
we spent a lot of lot of time on both of
the bills uh the first one that we
passed earlier today and this one
um my concern is that both bills because
they addressed similar uh base issues
and because they had the same fiscal
note due to the money being spent on um
system changes to accommodate those
changes that they were thrown in the
same basket and were considered two
kinds of apples that we could compare
and once we really um dug into it
I believed that it was not that easy
that they were um easily mergeable or a
one-size fitall kind of
solution
um the biggest part uh representative
Edwards alluded to was concerns about
domestic violence and situations of
abuse um in relation to the parenting
time calculator um we heard that uh some
Advocates believed that tying um
parenting time um directly um to the
Child Support guideline in situations of
households with abuse um was in and of
itself problematic and I don't believe
that um the bill as amended successfully
address
that my alternative I will be voting no
on the octopath as amended my my
alternative motion is not itl I simply
believe that a little more time has to
be taken to figure out how these two
bills can stand together to figure out
how those really difficult situations
when children are involved between um
parents that are not getting along and
not coming to agreement how we can put
children first so I would
um it's late I won't I'll just urge you
to please um vote no on the octopath
pass is amended so an alternative motion
of interim study could be made so that
we can make sure that this is the right
solution for kids here in the state
thank
you representative Edwards uh thank you
I I think one place I I I was relatively
clear is that uh these uh two bills hit
the same it system and there they share
a fiscal note um and so uh I I don't
believe I implied that from a policy
perspective they uh were intended to be
uh synergistic or aligned I it's just
that we can do both uh with without any
additional money uh and that the the
finding that this amendment takes care
of or this bill will take care of on an
otpa has been identified in multiple
reports as the right way to go and so it
is that we haven't looked at this issue
we've looked at this issue we've paid
probably a total of $400,000 for
multiple reports and I'm told it's more
than 400,000 and so I I think we ought
to we ought to just go ahead and U pass
this now while we can do the
implementation at uh at no extra cost so
I would uh definitely recommend uh a yes
vote on
otpa further discussion if you want to
keep your job all right we've have we
have adopted House Bill
1595 the uh and amended it with
Amendment 1178 the motion before us is
ought to pass as amended by house poll
house Amendment
1178 on House Bill 1595 motion by
representative Edwards second and by
representative Hull there's no further
discussion the clerk will call a rooll
on that motion thank you Mr chair
representative F yes representative uh
Maguire yes representative Petri vot yes
representative emri yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney
no representative uh Edwards
yes representative Bean
yes representative hle
yes representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes represent
puppa V meller yes Representative walner
no representative Lehman no
Representative buo
no representative uh Heath
no representative Murray no
representative eel no Representative
torski no representative haken Phillips
no represent Stringham
yes
president grassy
no president Priest
No representative wer
yes would you believe uh Mr chairman to
the vote is 13 to 11 in favor of the
motion okay we will uh put it in in the
regular calendar on the pass as amended
on house 1595 there'll be a m Minority
Report Minority Report from who's
representative
tersi and that's
aath and what would be your report AO
pass interim study interim
study thank
you all
right
Edwards we now move to House Bill
1573 representative Edwards okay okay
under the category last but not least um
this was uh uh House Bill
1573 represented a bill that um
encouraged division 3 to spend the most
time talking about it and uh and
probably the most activity um generated
by it uh for the community uh it came to
us um from Children and Family law um uh
talking to the chairman and the sponsor
of
1573 uh they stated categorically that
they never considered the finances as
they were putting the bill together uh
and they wanted you smart people in
finance to figure that out quote so so
with that permission
um we we reopened the policy portion of
the bill because it was important if we
were going to do something that we did
it in a way in which we got the initial
costs down the the initial fiscal note
on this I don't I don't remember exactly
what it is anymore U Mr Ripple if you do
it's like it's over $6 million or
something it was it was a fairly large
uh fiscal
note do you have it I can look it up now
I don't remember off the top of my head
$7.5 million a year 7 5 million um and
and so because we cared about the ocas
the office of child Advocates uh
recommendations that flowed uh from
their investigation at the bledo Academy
down in Tennessee you may have read
about it in the newspapers uh we had a
couple of kids there that according to
the OCA report um were uh in in a a
fairly abusive environment and it was uh
it was bad press and it looked bad
because uh DHHS it had sent employees
down there uh the week before OCA
checked it out and the the our uh DHHS
employees didn't find anything uh
significantly wrong they they uh but the
OCA did there were subsequent
third-party uh audits of uh bledo and uh
they didn't find the same things that
the OCA report did um but uh
nevertheless the OCA report is extremely
damning and something that we should
take cons uh seriously because uh the
DCF mandate or or placement of uh kids
out of state is a very serious
obligation or responsibility on our part
so so wanting it to succeed we asked OCA
and DH HS to keep working on uh uh an
accommodation of each other's interests
so that we could
streamline the the policy components and
try to get the costs down now the the
other thing that happened was for the
first time after we had begun meeting on
it we recognized that the judicial
branch had not been involved they had uh
a fiscal note in there of of two judges
and and nine clerks in order to support
1573 which was a huge growth in
Workforce and and cost so so we thought
the judicial branch ought to get in
there and help us figure it out
also that resulted in an amendment that
dropped the costs down
significantly but it left us with a
piece of law that would have been highly
prescriptive
highly prescriptive in a way in which
it's probably inappropriate for
statutory design it just got into too
much detail uh it also set up uh some
extreme uh not extreme some some
significant requirements in terms of uh
the number of visits and exactly how the
visits would take place and they they
didn't want to consider video
conferencing to be a legitimate way to
to check on a kid uh and so we still
ended up with a pretty expensive
Amendment um and I don't remember how
much that amendment was representative
Earth do you do you it was we didn't
have numbers we didn't have numbers it
it it was it I I I think it was still in
the5 to6 million range it was it was
still pretty intense because it would
have required 15 DHHS employees alone to
handle
this so um
so what this amendment does is it it
basically concurs with
1573 purpose and
findings and it does add a critical
policy component that it just seems to
be smart uh on on page two starting at
line nine that said it shall be the
policy of DHHS that any placement of a
child outside of New England shall
require the approval of the division for
children youth and families directors
prior to that placement with specific
findings of the need for that placement
so that that that part of what was in
the statute uh as proposed was was
really good and we kept it other vast
amounts of the other parts of the
proposed bill um have already been
implemented by DHHS DHHS has taken the
findings very seriously they've put it
into policy they're consuming resources
to execute in a more intensive
certification process and and visitation
process so so they're already doing the
work and so the question for the
legislature is to what extent do we
trust the commissioner to do her job um
know having had an opportunity to to see
the problems and and she has implemented
new policies to meet this this and
because they're burning resources uh in
excess of their original budget um the
Appropriations for from line 12 down to
17 gave them a million dollars to use
pretty much at the commissioner's
discretion and uh I've since talked to
her and uh she appreciates the approach
uh she she she's committed she committed
to me that this is a serious issue the
Departments work working on it it's got
everyone's focus and they need the
additional resources so so that million
dollars is a is a is a is a good thing
it's a complete wag uh you know what wag
is um wild ass guess uh based on um the
number of additional visits and all um
she said it would not exceed a million
dollars but we can work that out in more
detail with the Senate I've since also
talked to the Senate uh chair of finance
and when I told him it was a million
dollar he said we don't have a million
dollars I you know that's fiscally
irresponsible to ask for a million
dollars at this point in the process and
I pointed out that the alternative was
multiples of millions you know five or
six million and that a million dollars
was pretty fiscally responsible so so
I'm I begun advocating for this position
um um and I I I I I I don't think we're
done I think this continues the process
so uh I I never I never made a motion
for us to uh adopt 1309 um Mr chair um
but I would need a second if that's a
good
motion okay motion by representative
Edwards second by representative F to
adopt Amendment
1309 and and so this is a more of a
replace all than the other one so
um and I'm I'm done discussing this if
representa
walner thank
you so this was a bill that came to us
um from the children and family law
committee and they voted it out 15 to
zero and it was a Voice vote on the
floor of the
house and this is a response to a really
concerning issue that happened
um when the child advocate went to
Tennessee to visit two boys that were in
New Hampshire State custody and had been
placed in Tennessee in a
facility she wrote a report which any of
you can read and I think if you read it
you too will probably be
concerned um I think one of the most
serious things we
do as a
state is when we take custody of
people's children for whatever reason it
is and when we place them in facilities
I think the state has a real
responsibility to be sure that those
places are safe and the children are
receiving the treatment that the state
is paying those facilities for that is
not what um the child advocate found
when she went to
Tennessee there are probably
other
facilities that also are not meeting the
um obligations to children that they
have placed with them by the state what
the bill
does
is
prescribe as a representative Edwards
said it does
prescribe um a road map for the
department on the things that would be
expected and I don't think there's
anything the child advocate and the
department actually worked very hard for
the last several months on coming up
with a position that they could both um
feel maybe not not 100% but they got
pretty close they're probably at about
97% in agreement um on a on an amendment
that was brought to us last
Friday doing things such as requiring
that there be two visits a year two
visits to
um
places on a regular uh two visits I'm
sorry on a regular basis but one of them
being
unannounced so that the facility would
not know that um that someone was coming
and that's probably when you really
learn a lot each child would receive a
visit every month by their case
worker the bill that they came up with
on Friday the amendment that the
department came up with on Friday with
the child advocate um actually has in it
the uh Appropriations lined out as to
what the finances would be spent on and
the bill as it came to us on Friday the
amendment is about $1.9 million and you
can read for your I've got copies of
this amendment also you can read here
exactly how the money would be spent
and in the amendment before you right
now you're just giving the department a
million
dollars you are not prescribing at all
what they will do with it yes I know the
department of course wants to
do a good job attending to this but I
think it's the legislature's
responsibility to be sure we we do some
direction of how we want to see the
funds expended and in the amendment
before you right now there's not even a
report at the end you know in a year or
so there's not even a report back to the
legislature as to what is a what has
happened over the time that they've had
the um New
requirements I hope that the finance
committee will really think seriously
about whether the way we operate here is
just to give
departments blank checks basically and
say here hope you can get the job done I
think the legislature has a
responsibility for um prescribing how we
want to see these funds used and um
certainly the department and the child
advocates have worked long and hard to
come up with um a proposal that they
they can both um work from last week the
um director of the division of Children
and Families came before us his name is
Jeff Fletcher and he's pretty new and he
came before us and he told us the
division how much the department really
feels he feels they need this uh
legislation and um following his
following his guidance I think that um
the approach that this amendment is
before us right now takes is um not what
he needs for his
Department if the the amendment is goes
down I do have the um an amendment that
addresses the agreement between between
the child advocate and the department
that they came to last
week thank
you for the discussion representative
tersi thank you very much Mr chairman I
just wanted to add a couple quick points
that maybe representative wner didn't
touch on um we started with two groups
really far apart really far apart and it
was clear that they both had an idea of
where they needed to go and as the work
happened I applaud the people who were
on that subcommittee who worked on that
they got closer and closer no neither
one really got what they wanted but in
the end they were 97% there both the
office of child advocate and the
department sat there and they both said
we need guidelines we're doing it but we
want to be have it itemized and guard
rails put down so that everyone's clear
on what we're doing this amendment right
here here with a blank check in node gar
rails this is fiscally irresponsible to
just say I hope you can get it done you
say you're doing it when they're asking
for us to give them those
guidelines so again I hope you can
support um the argument that we have
here for the other amendment that
actually sets up the structure that the
Departments are asking us for and please
vote no on this amendment so another one
can be
introduced representative Edwards
as I said I I spoke with the
commissioner about this and I've spoken
with her many times before we have a
very good collegial relationship and uh
we both applauded the the work of Miss
Morris and and working out a tremendous
amount of detail um but I think
ultimately the commissioner is perfectly
fine with my Amendment she doesn't need
a lot of guidelines because they've
already implemented
the guidelines that have been drafted
into policies they are already doing the
work based on their own set of policies
and when we had the new DCF guy come in
the director come in uh he's he's he's
from New Jersey and and apparently he
wrote a very similar uh piece of
legislation to this for New Jersey and I
think that was a source of much of the
initial set of guidelines it it came in
heavy I mean even after all the great
work that the representative just cited
we still had 15 brand new
FTE you know and when you ask the
director what he thought about it he
said this is a cool Bill and he said and
oh by the way I'm coming back because we
need to build more capacity in state so
that we don't send people out so frankly
we went about a process that was
backwards instead of building the the
the inspection outplacement end of this
we should have been focusing on what's
it going to take to build the instate
capacity to reduce the demand this is
sort of poor systems design what this
bill represents and I I'm I'm I'm I'm
convinced that uh with the Senate
working on a companion bill that this is
not the last that the house has seen of
it this is this is our going back to
being able to get back to the Senate to
work continue working on this because
this this this bill was not cooked when
it came out of Children and Family Law
they didn't even consider the financial
impact they said that right I mean and
they said you guys you smart people have
to figure that out so so this this is an
attempt to avoid
building an empire that should be aged
out rapidly because we're instead
focusing on building capacity in New
Hampshire and you can only spend a
dollar once you can't keep spending the
same dollar over and over if we had
unlimited resources this would be among
the limited wants I would support but we
don't have unlimited resources thank you
further discussion on adoption of
amendment
1309 representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman it seems to me that that giving
the Department
flexibility um would have a better
outcome because they can then use their
own judgment as to which
facilities uh maybe they're new and
therefore need a little extra attention
which facilities have been run by the
the same competent people for a very
long time maybe they need a little less
things like that but if we if we have if
we micromanage exactly how they run
their Department uh costs are inevitably
going to be higher thank you further
discussion on the
amendment represent PRI thank you Mr
chairman again I I uh refer back to the
testimony and the statements made by my
fellow
Representatives um who who are citing
that both the department and the child
advocacy were
wanting more guidance and
structure to this problem and since this
problem is so serious and we are dealing
with the custody of children that are
our
responsibilities we have to make sure
that the structure is in place and the
alternative that that uh representative
walner was going to propose and is
proposing should be considered before we
we should uh move on this bill and so
therefore I recommend that we oppose
this amendment and consider another
amendment which clearly addresses the
concerns of both the department and the
child advocacy thank
you further discussion seeing none
without objection can we vote on this
amendment by
hands all in favor of amendment 130 9
raise your
hand three four six seven8 10 12
opposed one two three four
five 6 7 8 9 10 11 13 to
11 the motion is the amendment is
adopted representative Earth moves a to
to pass as amended second and a second
by representative Edwards on ought to
pass as amended on House Bill 1573
amended by Amendment
1309 further
discussion seeing none you're ready for
the question the clerk will call a rooll
on the motion of ought to pass thank you
Mr chairman representative ER yes
representative Maguire yes
representative Petri vote Yes
representative emrich yes representative
Griffin yes representative
Mooney could I just have a clarification
on the vote you said ought to pass this
is ought to pass with amendment is that
true I say that yeah you said amendment
I said ought to pass as amended by 1309
then my vote is yes thank you
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
Hull yes representative Sweeney yes
representative camell yes representative
Popovich Muller yes Representative
walner no Representative leichman no
Representative buo no representative uh
Heath
no representative Murray no
representative evil no Representative
torski no representative haken Phillips
no representative Stringham no
representative grassy no representative
Priest No representative wer yes Mr
chairman the vote is 13-1 in favor of
the
motion okay we have adopted uh house
bill
1573 as amended by
1309 is there anything else to come
before us um as you know I have I think
by my count I have looking for 10
majority reports four minority reports
uh before we leave today I hope you have
them already tomorrow we're coming back
again for uh the division 2 at
10:00 and Division 1 at 1:00 the work
sessions on the two
bills both at 10 o'cl all right 10 o'cl
uh for the two bills that we heard at 10
and
11 anything
further thank you all for your patience
thank you all for your hard work I'm
proud to be on this committee with all
the good information that comes forward
and all the good work that we do we are
adjourned